bonjour à tous dépenseer plus en gagnant
moins c'est la difficile équation que
doivent résoudre les collectivités
territoriales des collectivités qui
doivent faire face à des charges de plus
en plus nombreuses mais les recettes
diminuent et l'État ne compense plus
assez les transfer de compéten une
inquiétude des collectivités accrue par
la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle l'heure est donc à
l'optimisation des moyens c'est le but
du rapport de la délégation collectivité
territoriale et à la décentralisation
pour la délégation la solution c'est la
mutualisation la mise en commun des
moyens et pour cette délégation un
impératif absolu la délégation souhaite
que la mutualisation entre les
collectivités se fasse sur un simple
acord elle disposeraiit donc de plus de
moyens pour accomplir leurs tâches
respectives c'est sur la base de ce
rapport qu' lieu le débat dans
l'hémicycle à très bonne
séance l'ordre du jour appelle le débat
sur l'optimisation des moyens des
collectivité
territoriale la parole est à Monsieur
Alain Lambert président et rapporteur de
la délégation Collectiv territorial et à
la
décentralisation
ave respect tuas
bien monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues pour sa
première demande de débat en séance
publique votre toute jeune délégation de
la décentralisation qui a la chance de
compter dans ses rangs le président de
séance n'a pas choisi monsieur le
ministre un sujet théorique qui pourrait
faire controverse mais au contraire un
sujet pratique un sujet concret
qui vise à organiser la poursuite d'un
objectif d'intérêt général
l'optimisation de l'action publique
locale à partir d'idées à partir de
pistes d'évolution d'attente de pratique
qui émanent de nos territoires lesquels
territoires sont vous le savez en forte
demande sur cette question à l'heure où
les ressources sont comptées à l'heure
où les finances sont tendues à l'heure
où des dépenses
inéluctables profil T cell lié au
vieillissement qui pourrait en effet
être contre l'optimisation des moyens
des collectivités territoriales qui
pourrait regretter la recherche de la
meilleure efficacité le meilleur
rendement qui pourrait ne pas souhaiter
une amélioration constante des services
rendus à nos concitoyens au meilleur
rapport coût
efficacité personne évidemment sauf
peut-être le droit existant ou supposer
c'est dans cet esprit serein et
constructif que votre délégation s'est
longuement penchée sur une question clé
de la problématique de l'optimisation
celle de la mutualisation des
moyens cinq sénateurs membres de quatre
groupes différents se sont régulièrement
rencontrés ont tenu des auditions
auxquelles se sont souvent joints
d'autres sénateurs et ont échangé des
idées
bref cinq sénateurs ont travaillé
ensemble pour parvenir à un rapport
transpartisan formulant 13 propositions
et prenant en considération je le crois
les points de vue de chacun cinq
sénateurs pour quatre signatures notre
collègue Edmond Hervé n'a pas souhaité
figurer formellement escalité de
rapporteur mais je peux témoigner de la
part active qu'il a prise à nos réflexs
et tout particulièrement à la partie
dont je suis signataire sur la
problématique générale de la
mutualisation qui s'est largement
nourrie de ces observations pour ce qui
me concerne et afin d'éviter toute
redondance avec les interventions de mes
collègues rapporteurs je me B je me
bornerai à un point dont vous mesurez
tous l'importance dans le débat sur la
mutualisation ce point je l'ai appelé la
donne
communautaire cette donne comme
l'indique le rapport écrit a notablement
évolué au cours de la la période récente
de telle sorte que votre délégation
estime que l'on ne peut plus appréhender
aujourd'hui la question juridique
mutualisation droit communautaire comme
on le faisait il y a encore 18 mois bien
des portes se sont entrouvertes et il
est selon nous de notre devoir et je le
dis même avec solennité monsieur le
ministre de notre devoir de pousser ses
portes n'est-il pas temps d'en revenir à
une autre évidence qui semble avoir été
oublié le droit de la commande publique
n'est pas une finalité en soi c'est un
outil c'est un outil qui est au service
de valeur essentielle qui constitue
d'ailleurs sa raison d'être c'està-dire
l'éthique d'abord en fournissant des
critères objectifs à la sélection des
candidats l'efficacité de l'action
locale ensuite grâce à la mise en
concurrence laquelle permet à une
collectivité de retenir l'offre la plus
intéressante mais lorsque ni l'éthique
ni l'efficacité ne sont menacé recourir
à un marché public revient à administrer
un remède à une personne bien portante
c'est toujours inutile souvent coûteux
et parfois même nocif or en quoi
l'efficacité est-elle menacée par la
mise en commun des moyens et la
suppression de doublons inutiles en quoi
l'éthique est-elle menacée par le fait
qu' une collectivité publique puisse
demander à des agents publics de
participer à l'accomplissement de tâes
d'intérêt publ en collaboration avec une
autre collectivité publique dans le
cadre d'une convention de droit
publ j'insiste sur l'épithète publique
pour bien marquer le fait que je me
situe dans le cadre de tâche qui ne
relève pas de l'initiative privée soit
que celle-ci n'est pas vocation à les
accomplir je p bien sûr avant tout au
service public administratif soit
qu'elle n'existe pas ainsi conçu et
ainsi circonscrite et encadré dans les
conditions prévues par votre délégation
la mutualisation des moyens des
collectivités territorial bénéficiera à
chaque citoyen et ne portera atteinte à
aucun intérêt qu'il soit public ou qu'il
soit
privé je comprends que certains au
fonctionnaires européens hésitent à
franchir ti le cap bien que la Cour de
justice selon nous a été suffisamment
claire je ne conteste pas que le droit
des marchés publics soit pour reprendre
la formule de certains avocats généraux
que je cite l'un des instruments
politiques les plus influents de
l'intégration européenne mais comme le
disent les mêmes personnes ses avocats
généraux au combien autorisés je les
cite il ne peut cet instrument il ne
peut être utilisé de manière
inconsidérée de sur croix il n'est qu'un
instrument ce n'est pas une valeur en
soi et je me dis parfois que dans les
sociétés développées on arrive à
confondre valeur et instrument ce qui
était la pire perversion de l'esprit il
ne saurait être mis sur le même plan que
le droit de l'autonomie locale ou que le
principe de bonne administration qui
sont tous deux consacrés comme valeur et
non pas comme instrument comme valeur au
niveau européen enfin ai-je besoin de
rappeler à nouveau ici la nécessité et
l'urgence de faire face aux évolutions
démographiques sociologiques économiques
au auxquel sont aujourd'hui confrontés
nos collectivités territorial notre
collègue bruno Sido qui n'a pu être des
nôtres ce matin a parfaitement mis
l'accent sur la situation des
départements mais c'est pour toutes les
collectivités que votre délégation vous
lance aujourd'hui un appel monsieur le
ministre minist agissons alors monsieur
le ministre nous demandons instamment
instamment au gouvernement de ne pas
céder à la tentation d'une prudence
excessive au regard du droit
communautaire ne laissons pas la
Commission européenne s'enfermer dans
une contradiction qui verrait l'une de
ces directions générales engendré pour
les collectivités territoriales des
dépenses inutiles pendant qu'une autre
direction générale nous rappellerait à
nos devoirs de maîtrise des dépenses
publiques il y aurait là une
contradiction dans laquelle il ne faut
pas laisser la commission s'enfermer ce
qui ne serait pas un comportement
européen voilà monsieur le ministre ne
nous abandonnez pas dans notre combat
nous ne le menons pas au nom d'une
quelconque idéologie mais tout
simplement au nom de notre devoir et de
notre responsabilité je vous remercie
beaucoup de votre
attention merci monsieur le Président
Lambert maintenant la parole est à
Monsieur d rapporteur de la délégation
au collecté territoriale et la
décentralisation monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
aussi loin que l'on remonte dans les
origines de l'intercommunité on constate
que celle-ci a toujours été conçue avec
pour objectif principal de mutualiser
des moyens au service d'un territoire
cependant si l'intercommunalité est
aujourd'hui très développée et si on va
même vers la généralisation
l'intercommunité fiscalité propre sur
l'ensemble du territoire dans les
prochaines années il est clair que l'on
n'est pas allé au bout de cette logique
de mutualisation et ceci pour plusieurs
raisons d'une part parce que les
intercommunalités sont des personnes
morales distinctes des communes qui les
composent et qu'elles doivent donc
logiquement procéder leur propres
service d'autre part par qu'en exigeant
que tout transfert de compétences des
communes vers un établissement public de
coopération intercommunale s'accompagne
je cite du transfert du service ou de la
partie de service en charge de sa mise
en œuvre le code général des
collectivités territoriales a en quelque
sorte provoqué un cloisonnement entre
l'intercommunalité et ses communes
membres à chacun ses services et ses
moyens quand bien même ceci ferait
doublon pour autant en permettant de
mettre les services d'une commune membre
à disposition d'une intercommunalit pour
l'exercice de ces compétences lorsque
cette mise à disposition présente un
intérêt dans le cadre d'une bonne
organisation des services je cite là
encore le code général des collectivités
territoriales le législateur a permis
que les services support d'une commune
par exemple ces services de gestion du
personnel des marchés publics des
finances de l'informatique puissent
intervenir également pour la communauté
la mutualisation que l'on pourrait donc
qualifier de verticale entre entre
intercommunalité et des communes membres
et dans certains cas
possibles néanmoins il existe un type de
mutualisation qui pose encore problème
au sein de l'intercommunalité qui est
celui que l'on pourrait qualifier de
mutualisation horizontale c'est-à-dire
de mise en commun de moyens entre deux
ou plusieurs communes de la même
intercommunalité pour l'exercice de
compéten qui n'ont pas été transféré à
celle-ci or ceci est tout à fait
important si l'on veut que le territoire
intercommunal soit de plus en plus vécu
comme un véritable espace de coopération
au-delà même de la coopération
institutionnelle qui s'exerce au travers
de la communauté et si l'on veut
renforcer les relations entre communes
voisines pourquoi par exemple ne pas
permettre que la cuisine centrale d'une
commune puisse sans mise en concurrence
et dans un simple cadre conventionnel
fournir des repas pour la restauration
scolaire d'une autre commune de la même
intercommunalité pourquoi ne pas
permettre que les services chargés du
fleurissement ou de l'entretien des
bâtiments dans une commune membre
puissent intervenir sans formalisme
particulier dans la petite commune
voisine de la même intercommunalité qui
ne possède pas elle-même les services
compétents si ce type de coopération
conventionnel semble pouvoir se mettre
en place sans difficulté pour la gestion
des services publics administratifs en
raison de la proximité de cette notion
très française avec la notion européenne
de service non économique d'intérêt
général il n'en est pourtant pas de même
en matière de coopération pour les
services communaux qui peuvent être
qualifiés toute chose égale par ailleurs
de servicees industriel et commerciaux
et dont la gestion en vertu de la
réglementation européenne relative au
servicees économique d'intérêt général
ne peut pas être attribué sans mise en
concurrence si la jurisprudence
européenne dans ce domaine évolue et
donne lieu aujourd'hui à des
interprétation nuancée le président
Lambert vient de le rappeler à l'instant
il semble bien pourtant que toute
mutualisation entre personne morale de
droit public pour l'accomplissement d'un
service public autre qu'administratif ne
puisse être conforme au droit
communautaire de la commmentande
publique que si elle se traduit par une
véritable coopération entre les
cocontractants coopération qui est
distincte d'une prestation de service
dans laquelle une des deux collectivités
se contenterait de participer
financièrement or nous sommes convaincus
de l'intérêt de favoriser ce type de
coopération entre communes à l'intérieur
d'une même intercommunalité d'une part
parce que cela permet d'optimiser
l'utilisation des services existants et
d'autre part parce que pour beaucoup de
petites communes le coût le formalisme
la complexité des démarches de mise en
concurrence sont souvent décourageants
et j'allais dire excèdent de tout point
de vue le coût le coût excès de
l'intérêt de cette démarche il est
d'ailleurs intéressant de constater que
les exemples de coopération entre
communes à l'intérieur d'un territoire
intercommunal tendent à se multiplier
dans des domaines très divers comme nous
avons pu le constater au cours des
auditions auxquelles nous avons procédé
ces dernières semaines et comme l'a
démontré il y a une quinzaine de jours
un colloque organisé à la Caisse des
dépôts et cela se traduit j'ajouterai
que cela se traduit également par une
optimisation de l'utilisation des moyens
humains et matériels de la commune qui
en dispose donc nous avons tout intérêt
au regard des reproches qui ont été
faits non seulement par la Cour des
comptes mais par par d'autres organismes
à l'intercommunalité que l'on accuse de
multiplier les services au lieu de
rationaliser nous avons donc tout
intérêt à avancer dans cette direction
c'est pour cette raison que nous
proposons notamment d'élargir le champ
des mutualisations purement
conventionnelle en autorisant outre la
mutualisation des services fonctionnels
pour la satisfaction de besoins
d'intérêt général ayant un caractère
administratif les mutualisations pour la
satisfaction de besoins d'intérêt
général à caractère industriel ou
commercial à condition que celle-ci
consiste en de véritables coopération
entre cocontractants nous proposons
également de permettre aux communes
membres d'un même groupement
intercommunal d'avoir des agents communs
pour l'exercice de leur mission de
service public dont la compétence n'a
pas été transférée ainsi que pour tenir
compte des faibles moyens de beaucoup de
communes et du montant souvent limité
des prestations pouvant faire l'objet de
ce type de mutualisation de saisir nos
partenaires européens de la possibilité
d' dicter en quelque sorte une règle de
minimis applicable à la mutualisation
des moyens destinés à accomplir des
services économiques d'intérêt général
je rappelle en effet à titre de
comparaison que dans le domaine de la
concurrence les aides d'État d'un
montant n'excédant pas 200000 € sur 3
ans sont exonérés des règles de mise en
concurrence communautaire en effet
l'article 106 du traité sur le
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne
permet de déroger au règles de
concurrence pour un
service un service économique d'intérêt
général dès lors que je cite cela
n'entrave pas le développement des
échanges dans une mesure contraire à
l'intérêt de l'Union convenons que la
coopération la mutualisation des moyens
à l'intérieur d'une intercommunaité en
règle générale pour ne pas dire dans la
totalité des cas et bien n'entrave pas
le développement des échanges dans une
mesure contraire à l'intérêt de l'Union
voilà Monsieur le Ministre quelques une
des propositions que nous souhaiterions
voir se concrétiser mon collègue Jacques
mzard va en évoquer d'autres donc dans
ce domaine de la mutualisation à
l'intérieur des intercommunalités nous
espérons vraiment comme l'a dit le le le
président Lambert pouvoir compter sur
l'appui du du gouvernement pour y
parvenir car ces mesures outre qu'elles
conforteront l'intercommunalité et Dieu
sait si c'est un des volets cent Trux du
débat qui va de l'Assemblée au Sénat sur
la réforme des collectivités
territoriales donc outre qu'elles
conforteront l'intercommunalité elles
simplifieront la gestion de nos communes
et constitueront un élément de réponse
au reproches trop facilement fait aux
intercommunalités d'augmenter
inconsidérément leurs
services merci Monsieur det maintenant
nous allons entendre Monsieur Jacques
mzard vice-président et rapporteur de la
délégation colcté territoriale et à la
décentralisation monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues si un premier élément que nous
pouvons extraire du travail réalisé par
la
délégation c'est que la mutualisation
est une notion dont la mise en
application n'a pas été facilitée par
les règles
européennes ni par les règles nationale
alors qu'il est grand temps de la
développer dans l'intérêt de nos
collectivités et donc de nos concitoyens
je ne reviendrai pas sur l'excellent
exposé du président Lambert qui a posé
la question de la jurisprudence
européenne de son évolution quand même
président assez positive depuis 2 ans ou
un peu plus de 2 ans que nous avions
déjà observé monsieur le ministre dans
le récent débat unanimes sur les
sociétés publiques locales et nous ne
doutons pas de l'action positive sur ce
point du gouvernement auprès des
autorité européenne sur le plan national
notre réflexion s'est poursuivie en en
plein débat du projet de loi sur la
réforme des collectivités territoriales
le Sénat à travers un amendement du
président Lambert avait au niveau de
l'article des articles 34 faciliter la
mutualisation et le texte aujourd'hui en
discussion propose l'insertion de deux
articles nouveaux du Code Général des
Collectivités le
l521 4 2 et 3 il y est clairement
affirmé que les EPCI à fiscalité propre
et une ou plusieurs communes membres
peuvent se doter de services communs
ceci est un incontestable progrès avec
Yve desreg et la délégation en
travaillant sur la mutualisation des
moyens dans le cadre
intercommunal nous avons naturellement
travaillé sur ce qui est un moyen de
développer l'intercommunalité certes
l'aboutissement de l'organisation
intercom communale c'est le transfert de
compétences accompagné du transfert de
charg permettant une gestion du service
au niveau de leepci et le plus souvent
de l'extension de nouveaux services à
des communes membres c'est l'apogé et la
fin de la mutualisation mais c'est une
belle fin cependant la mutualisation a
un intérêt de plus en plus évident
d'abord elle peut-être une étape
transitoire vers cet apogé ou tout
simplement être un instrument de gestion
plus efficace de par la mise en place de
servicees commun et à ce moment de la
discussion il m'a paraît important de
relever un point fondamental avec Liv de
traigne nous avons
considéré que l'objectif réaliste de la
mutualisation n'était pas de dépenser
moins encore moins monsieur le ministre
de dépenser plus
mais de dépenser mieux et donc de gérer
mieux cela ne veut pas dire monsieur le
ministre qu'aucune économie n'est à
espérer sinon vous
désespéreriez mais vraisemblablement pas
à court terme il est plus sage pour nous
de considérer la mutualisation comme un
moyen d'éviter à terme des dépenses
supplémentaires n'oublions pas aussi la
vocation fortement péréquatrice de
l'intercommunalité et de la
mutualisation qui apporte de fait de
nouveaux services à des communes qui
n'en disposaient pas cette péréquation
qualitative ne figure pas dans un bilan
comptable mais elle participe de
l'essentiel de l'amélioration des
services rendus à nos
concitoyens nous avons compris que pour
un temps certain il était peu réaliste
d'envisager un concours de l'État par
des incitations financières pour
développer intercommunalité et
mutualisation dire autre chose ne serait
pas non plus très réaliste en revanche
selon nous l'État doit effacer les
obstacles juridiques avec la mise en
place d'un dispositif juridique
sécurisant et
responsabilisant facilitant donc la
mutualisation peut-être aussi monsieur
le ministre dans la foulée faire passer
le message au contrôle de l'égalité que
la mutualisation n'est pas une espèce
nuisible cela pourrait être utile Yve de
trgne a décrit cinq propositions de
notre rapport de l'élargissement du
champ des mutualisation purement
conventionnel pour les services
fonctionnels à cell des servicees
opérationnels des communes dans
l'attente de leur
transfert jusqu'à l'édiction d'une règle
de minimis applicable à la mutualisation
des moyens destinés à accomplir des
services d'intérêt économique général il
m'appartient donc dans ce volet du
rapport d'insister plus fortement sur la
réflexion que nous avons développé
relative à la mise en place éventuelle
d'un dispositif financier à la fois
incitatif et neutre pour le budget de
l'État vraiment vous voyez que nous
avons fait des efforts considérables
monsieur ministre nous avons écarté la
solution d'un prêt de l'État pour
mutualisation nous avons pensé que le
moment n'était peut-être pas bien venu
pour faire une telle proposition et en
plus les inconvénients techniques nous
paraissaient plus fort que les avantages
nous avons par contre considérer qu'il
serait intéressant d'avancer vers
l'instauration d'un dispositif de bonus
malus pour les dotations de l'État sous
forme d'un coefficient d'intégration
fonctionnelle nous connaissons le
fonctionnement du coefficient
d'intégration fiscale qui est très
compliqué mais finalement qui a quand
même un certain nombre
d'avantages ce coefficient d'intégration
fonctionnelle mesurerait le rapport
entre des moyens évaluer de manière
objective et en se référant au temps de
travail des personnels dans un premier
temps ce coefficient pourrait être
calculé pour la prise en compte des
seuls services fonctionnels
ce coefficient serait donc calculé en
fonction du rapport entre d'une part les
équivalent temps plein affectés à des
services fonctionnels ayant donné lieu à
mutualisation et d'autre part l'ensemble
des équivalents temps plein affecté des
services fonctionnels de toutes les
communes membres et au sein de l' PCI il
servirait donc à augmenter
proportionnellement la DGF des EPCI
situé au-dessus de la moyenne et et a
diminuer celle des EPCI situé au-dessous
de la moyenne selon un critère et une
méthode de fonctionnement qui est déjà
mise en place dans d'autres secteurs
enfin monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues nous avons considéré qu'il
n'était pas
souhaitable d'aller dans la voie d'un
dispositif
contraignant érigeant la mutualisation
en obligation de résultat dans le cadre
intercommunal par par contre nous avons
proposé que soit instauré le principe
d'un débat annuel d'orientation
budgétaire nous avons proposé
il un débat annuel peut-être serait-il
plus sage de se diriger vers deux débats
au cours d'une
mandature peut-être un au cours de la
première année un à la 4e ou 5e année
pour ne pas surcharger de débat nos
exécutifs donc instauration d'un débat
d'orientation budget entre exécutif de
leepci et ceux des communes membres avec
inscription obligatoire à l'ordre du
jour de l'examen d'un schéma de
mutualisation des
services ça ne coûte rien et c'est un
moyen de faire par la concertation et
l'échange approfondi d'information entre
exécutif un moyen de faciliter la
réflexion et les démarches de travail en
commun qui ne sont pas toujours
évidentes et qui nécessitent cette
rencontre et ce travail en commun c'est
aussi monsieur le ministre de cette
manière que nous ferons confiance à
l'intelligence territoriale cher au
Sénat de la
République
merci alors maintenant nous allons
entrer dans le vif du débat je rappelle
que la Conférence des présidents
organiser le débat la première
intervenantead va être madame
marie-fance Beaufils au nom du groupe
CRC
SPG monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers
collègues le discours sur l'optimisation
a un caractère assez
incantatoire en effet qui pourrait être
opposé à l'idée d'utiliser au mieux les
moyens à disposition des collectivités
territoriales rationaliser l'usage des
ressources apporté par le contribuable
local ne serait-ce que pour libérer des
moyens financiers pour répondre plus
efficacement aux nouveaux besoins qui
s'expriment aux créations au
développement des services publics qui
permettent d'y faire face répondre aux
besoins collectifs tels qu'il s'exprime
au niveau local n'impliquet-il pas de
savoir trouver les voies et moyens d'une
juste et efficace à loocation des
recettes fiscales comme budgétaire dont
disposent les élus locaux nous pouvons
prêter au rapport de nos collègues de la
délégation toute l'attention qu'il
mérite ne serait-ce que pour partager le
constat d'une tension particulière des
budgets locaux singculièrement
d'ailleurs depuis 2004 avec la loi
liberté responsabilité locale bien
souvent appelé second acte de la
décentralisation mais qui en est bien
loin mais c'est surtout à
l'accroissement des transfert des
responsabilités de l'État vers les
collectivités que nous avons à faire
face et le mouvement n'a fait que
simplifier avec la
volonté de les faire participer à la
réduction des déficits public n'hésitant
pas en même temps à les solliciter comme
en 2009 pour donner un coup de pouce à
l'économie faut-il pour autant ainsi que
nous y invite le rapport mettre en œuvre
tout ce qui pourrait permettre deé des
économies d'échelle en passant par une
mutualisation accrue des moyens
matériels et
humains je ne le pense pas comme je l'ai
rappelé en avril dernier lors de la
commission cette attitude me semble-t-il
d saaisie peu à peu les collectivités
les plus petites de leur capacité à
assumer leur mission leur choix
politique auprès de la population cela
peu à terme mettre en cause la clause de
compétence générale pourtant inscrite
dans la loi de décentr isation de 82
j'ai bien lu la les propositions de nos
collègues sur la mise en place d'un
dispositif financier incitatif et neutre
pour le budget de l'État la
préconisation de faire varier la DGF des
communes comme des groupements en
fonction de la proportion des effectifs
mutualisés par rapport aux effectifs
totaux des collectivités concernées
c'est-à-dire en quelque sorte désigner
les bons et les mauvaises élèves en
matière de coopération intercommunale et
de mutualisation
ne peut recueillir mon soutien mais
suscite plutôt mon profond désaccord
c'est refusé de reconnaître la diversité
des situation des collectivités ce
serait refusé que les collectivités
gardent des services publics là où
d'autres ont fait le choix
d'externaliser les bons ceux qui font
des gains de productivité en réduisant
l'importance de leurs équipes de terrain
seraiit
récompensé aujourd'hui ces propositions
partent de l'idée que le contexte
financier je cite pousse inéluptablement
au développement de la mutualisation et
de
l'intercommunalité la vérité des faits
c'est que le bilan de la
Décentralisation et des transfert de
compétenence est si déséquilibré qu'il
convient de faire quelque chose en tout
cas de proposer autre chose or ceux qui
depuis 2004 ont voté tous les textes qui
ont accompagné le mouvement de
désengagement de l'État et
d'accentuation de transfert de charges
sur les collectivités veulent inciter
les collectivités à se serrer la
ceinture à participer d'une certaine
manière
à la mission de réduction des dépenses
publiques que le gouvernement actuel
entend mener pour l'État cette
proposition incitative à la
mutualisation ressemble fort en tout cas
c'est comme ça que je l'ai ressenti à
une anticipation avant le vote de notre
assemblée de la réforme des
collectivités territoriales et
particulièrement la volonté de créer ces
futures communes nouvelles dont l'objet
est sur le fond la fin de nos
communes si nos collectivités souffrent
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elles n'ont plus
les moyens de faire face aux obligations
transférées par la loi ou comme le dit
aussi l'un de nos rapporteurs pour paser
au désengagement de l'État dans des
secteurs de plus en plus nombreux et je
crois que tout le monde le constate en
effet le bilan est lourd vous le savez
un certain nombre de départements on
nous dit une vingtaine sont au bord du
couffreou en quasi cation de paiement et
je crois que dans les conseils généraux
tout le monde sait combien il est
difficile de se retrouver avec
l'entretien et la mise aux norme d'un
route nationale importante quand l'État
n'a jamais pensé à financer son passage
à quatre voix mais comme notre collègue
bruno Sido n'est pas présent je pense
qu'il ne nous répondra pas sur le sujet
Comment faire face à la croissance
continue des dépenses liées au RSA
l'autonomie des personnes âgées quand on
est dans un département on frappe
l'exode des jeunes et la
désindustrialisation pilotée par les
grands goupres et les fonds
spéculatifs et à tout cet ensemble pour
le moins déstabilisant s'ajoute la
réforme des finances locales avec la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
elle fait perdre toute visibilité aux
élus locaux sur l'avenir des services
publics qu'ils assurent ce qui comme l'a
bien rappelé le ministre du Budget
monsieur Verz a pourant permis d'amortir
les conséquences de la crise dans notre
pays à cela s'ajoutent des situations
pour le moins incohérentes certaines
collectivités confronté à des besoins
sociaux particuliers seraiit aujourd'hui
mise à contribution pour compenser les
pertes de ressources entre la taxe
professionnelle et l'école la
contribution économique territoriale ma
collègue Gita oaro m'a fait remarquer
que la Réunion en tant que département
et régions serait soumise à contribution
bénéfice du Fond national de garantie
individuelle de ressources ce qui est
quand même surprenant quand on est dans
une collectivité au moins de 30 % de la
population résidante paye l'impôt sur le
revenu or l'éloignement de la fameuse
clause de revoyure cette carotte offerte
aux parlementaires rétiscents l'automne
dernier risque de plus en plus
s'apparenter à l'arlaisienne et à
nourrir l'inquiétude sur le terrain un
nouvel aspect va venir dégrader encore
plus la capacité des collectivités à
répondre à leur population c'est bien
entendu l'annonce du gel des dotations
budgétaires des
collectivité cette simple reconduction
en eururocourant va faire des élus
locaux de simples partenaires obligés de
la réduction des déficit les
contraignants au faux choix entre hausse
des impôts et des tarifs et baisse du
service publ local pourtant leur
contribution est essentielle à la
dynamique économique dont notre pays
aurait bien besoin dans ce paysage
morose pour les demandeurs
d'emploi proposer la mutualisation pour
optimiser nos moyens au moment où l'État
ne prop propose non pas de mutualisation
de mutualiser excusez-moi ces moyens
avec ceux des collectivités mais les
supprime tout simplement n'est-ce pas
accepter de nouveaux transferts
regardons avec intérêt en tout cas
monsieur semble-t-il toutes les mesures
qui fleurissent depuis quelques temps
sur la petite enfance cela a commencé
par la réduction des impôts pour les
foyers qui font assurer la garde de
leurs enfants à domicile on sait bien
que ce ne sont pas les plus modestes qui
en bénéficient après cette première
mesure on a vu apparaître une
proposition de jardin d'éveil prenant en
charge leses les jeunes enfants les
mêmes âges qu'en école maternelle leur
action étant assimilé à celle de l'école
justifiant ainsi la participation des
collectivités locales à leur fonction
fnement mais sans contribution de l'État
par contre le service rendu aux familles
serait payant en même temps les
ouvertures de classe en maternel
deviennent de plus en plus difficile
l'accueil des plus jeunes 2 ans et demi
s'am menuise autre nouveauté les
assistantes maternel peuvent maintenant
accueillir quatre enfants à domicile en
même temps les coupes sombres dans le
nombre des personnels de l'Éducation
nationale s'accentuent et toujours en
même temps le gouvernement demande aux
caises d'allocation familiale de moins
dépenser pour les contrat petit enfant
passer avec les collectivités
territoriales mais cela ne suffit
toujours pas aujourd'hui le gouvernement
vudrait regrouper quatre assistantes
maternelles dans un même lieu mis à
disposition par les collectivités ainsi
ces enfants d'âge maternel pourrait être
dans un même espace ce ne serait pas une
crèche l'encandrement ne serait pas le
même cet exemple montre s'il en est
besoin comment sous prétexte de réduire
des coûts sous prétexte de maîtriser la
dépense publique l'État casse une
formidable conception qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui la France a le meilleur
taux de renouvellement de la population
par rapport aux autres pays d'Europe
celle de la prise en charge de la petite
enfance y ayant largement contribué
c'est une autre conception de la société
que le gouvernement veut mettre en place
à marche forcée détruisant toute cette
richesse qui a permis à des milliers et
des milliers d'enfants de développer
leurs capacités dans de meilleures
conditions je pense à tous nos enfants
bien sûr des quartiers populaires issus
ou de l'immigration qui ont trouvé aussi
des possibilités d'épanouissement les
préparant mieux à leur futur scolarité
cette logique d'une société où peu à peu
tout ce qui peut contribuer à construire
dans de meilleures conditions l'avenir
des plus modeste nous ne pouvons
l'accepter cette logique c'est celle
qu'impose le système capitaliste dans
lequel nous sommes avec cette exigence
de rémunération des capitaux au
détriment particulièrement du
développement industriel au détriment de
l'emploi dont on voit la nociivité avec
plus de clarté depuis ces de dernières
années nous pensons qu'une autre
optimisation doit être au cœur de nos
réflexions c'est celle qui fera que les
richesses produites servent au
développement humain à la protection de
notre environnement plutôt qu'à
l'enrichissement de quelques-uns la
mutualisation laissons en effet la
possibilité aux élus locaux de la
décider sur la base de leur projet la
mutualisation
ou non en effet ne doit pas être sur la
base de mesures incitative vous me direz
que j'ai été sélective dans les mesures
que j'ai ciblé par rapport aux
préconisations qui ont été faites par
nos collègues mais je crois que ce qui
doit nous guider c'est en effet la
meilleure réponse aux besoins des
habitants et je crois que ce doit être
notre guide dans notre
action merci
Madame
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue monsieur Edmond Hervet pour le
groupe
socialiste monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre monsieurs les
rapporteurs chers
collègues le grand chantier de la
réforme de jeun administration locale
sera ouvert dès le mois de janvier voilà
ce que monsieur le Président de la
République annonçait à Toulon le 25
septembre 2008 au nom je cite de la
compétitivité de notre économie qui ne
peut supporter un poids excessif de
dépenses publiques il développera ce
thème lors d'un second grand discours à
saint-disier le 20 octobre 2009 et tout
naturellement notre Assemblée a eu et
aura à connaître de ce grand chantier
dans le flot très riche des
observations je veux en retenir une
largement partagé et d à
jean-pierrearin pour qui il e été
nécessaire avant de légiférer à nouveau
de faire le bilan de la
décentralisation celui-ci aurait eu de
très nombreux mérite notamment la
transparence source d'objectivité et de
loyauté mérite également de nous
éclairer sur la pratique de la
mutualisation des moyens par nos
collectivités territoriales c'est un
existant qu'il importe de connaître et
de développer et je demeure convaincu
que le rapport de nos collègues Alain
Lambert il de trgne Jacques mzard et
Bruno sidau favorisera ce processus par
la nouveauté de ses éclairages son
pragmatisme ses identifications et
propositions vous avez bien voulu
monsieur le président de la délégation
dans l'introduction de votre
intervention rappeler ma partie
iticipation soyez-en remerciés il n'a
pas échappé à votre présidence serereine
attentive et constructive que je ne
pouvais pas m'associer à un premier
projet d'orientation qui faisait de la
mutualisation des moyens je cite une
initiative administrative et non
politique un enjeu essentiel de la
maîtrise des dépenses publiques locales
le remède à la multiplication des
personnels communautaires les effectifs
des communes ayant continué de croître
nonobstant les nombreux transfert de
compétences au profit des EPCI fin de
citation je reconnais aux premières
pagees de votre rapport des atténuations
bienvenues et ind différent demeure
toujours vertueux dès lors qu'il exprime
des fidélités et nourrit un dialogue
républicain auquel nous sommes l'un et
l'autre attachés et au nom de celui-ci
retrouvons les finalités de la
mutualisation qui nous concerne
qu'est-elle vous en donnerz une très
juste définition dans le gloss de la fin
de votre rapport et c'est un processus
d'organisation et de valorisation qui a
pour finalité la réponse à des attentes
la qualité l'efficacité de l'action
publique le respect des principes du
service public et bien évidemment
l'utilisation optimale des ressources
qu'il s'agisse de la compétence des
personnes de l'utilisation des moyens
techniques ou de la disponibilité
financière cette mutualisation peut
prendre des formes les plus diverses
allant de la gestion d'un temps partiel
d'un agent à la gestion d'un équipement
intégré pouvant réunir nos collectivités
territoriales l'état des personnes de
droit public ou de droit privé elle peut
suivre aussi des scénaris très
différents suivant que l'on est dans
telle ou telle ville dans tel ou tel
département et la mutualisation n'est
pas un caprice d'affichage ou d'autorité
elle ne dépossède pas c'est une manière
d'envisager l'avenir moment de réflexion
elle permet d'anticiper des évolutions
institutionnelles et surtout ne la
confondons pas avec le transfert de
compétences ce sont deux logiques
totalement différentes la mutualisation
relève du principe constitutionnel de
libre administration et monsieur le
ministre permettez-moi au point où nous
en sommes de nos travaux
parlementaires de vous dire que nous
avons peut-être quelques réflexions
supplément à faire et qu'il est
difficile de parler de la mutualisation
si département et régions sont enfermés
dans des blocs de compétences exclusifs
et cette idée de bloc de compéten
exclusive m'a toujours paru attentatoire
au principe de libre
contractualisation c'est pourquoi je ne
cesse de militer pour le principe au
bénéfice de la région des départements
de compéten obligatoire non exclusive
alors y a-t-il des conditions à la
réussite de cette mutualisation je n'en
citerai qu'une la confiance que nous
devons toujours retrouver au cœur de nos
collectivités et au cœur de la relation
entre l'État et celle-ci confiance dans
le principe dans son projet
préalablement délibéré puis mis en œuvre
confiance entre les décideurs entre
ceuxci et les agents concernés qui
seront rassurés par un accord sur la
gestion du personnel il n'est pas
inutile de voir au niveau local une
conférence de la mutualisation de son
suivi de son évaluation c'est cette
conférence qui vous évitera la déception
la mutualisation portera bien souvent au
départ sur des services de gestion dont
le poids financier est marginal dans
l'ensemble concerné alors mes chers
collègues ne vous faites pas trop
d'illusion sur l'importance des
premières économies réalisées la
réussite suppose bien évidemment une
part parfaite définition de l'activité
concernée et c'est alors qu'il faut
rencontrer le droit
communautaire reprenons les dernières
ligne du rapport d'Alain Lambert page 27
je cite on ne peut donc le nier c'est
délibérément toute connaissance de cause
que la Cour de Justice a offert aux
responsables politiques des opportunités
pour développer la mutualisation ceuxci
ont le devoir de les saisir fin de
citation il faut oser et eu égard à
l'importance que nous conférons à la
mutualisation je partage l'optimisme de
notre président la jurisprudence de la
Cour sans surprise se réfère certes au
droits des marchés publics mais
également au droits de l'autonomie
locale consacré par la Charte européenne
de l'autonomie locale et la Commission
dans son avis motivé du 27 juin 2007
versait dans l'absurde puisqu'elle
remettait en cause la possibilité pour
une commune de mettre ses services à
disposition intercommunale et dans le
même temps nous disait qu'une communauté
pouvait mettre ses services à
disposition de la commune et je pense
qu'une telle incohérence ne rapproche
pas nécessairement les responsables
locaux de l'Europe alors d'où vient
cette dissonance entre court et
commission bien tout simplement de
l'absence de définition de la notion de
service non économique d'intérêt général
pour qui le code des marchés publics et
de la concurrence ne s'applique pas
alors qu'il s'applique au service
économique d'intérêt général et nous
voyons tout l'intérêt qu'il y aurait à
l'existence d'un texte droit positif
mais nous avons vu lorsque nous étions à
Bruxelles que à Bruxelles il y avait une
inclinaison culturelle vers une démarche
à l'anglo-saxonne qui se sépare du
cartésianisme des définitions qui sont
les nôtres et tout comme vous monsieur
Lambert eu je me permets de suggérer à
monsieur le ministre selon votre
expression de pousser les portes alors
puiss en l'attente de la Cour de justice
être aussi bien inspirée dans ces
décisions que notre Conseil d'État et
s'il y a là incertitude et attente je
souhaite terminer mon intervention par
l'expression d'une conviction
déterminée la poursuite et
l'approfondissement de la coopération
intercommunale constitue une absolue
nécessité la révision générale des
politiques publi de l'État amène un
rétrécissement des services déconcentrés
de l'État et bon nombre de communes et
communautés se trouvent désemparé au nom
de la démocratie de la décentralisation
et du développement nous leur devons une
sécurité juridique et technique le
département en charge de la solidarité
territoriale en lien avec l'État la
Région les principaux EPCI doit assurer
à ces communes établissement conseils et
expertise les responsables des acteurs
locaux n'ont de sens dans leur
implication que s'ils peuvent en
bénéficier vous comprendrez monsieur le
ministre dans le même état d'esprit que
je sois hostile à l'égard de tout projet
qui amoindrirait la fonction de contrôle
et d'évaluation des chambres régionales
des comptes les éloigneraiit des
territoires je seraai dans la même
disposition pour les mêmes raisons de
sécurité des acteurs à l'égard de tout
projet d'éventuell certification privée
des comptes publics je termine monsieur
le Président je retrouve le discours de
saint-disier monsieur le Président de la
République entendait faire participer
les collectivités territoriales à la
réduction de nos déficits elles peuvent
le faire et doivent le faire de
différentes manières y compris par des
stratégies de croissance et de
développement dès lors qu'on leur en
laisse les moyens j'ai parle du
confiance voilà la première ressource
que vous leur devez elles vous le
rendront bien et nous le prouve
quotidiennement merci
merci Monsieur maintenant la parole est
à Monsieur Philippe
ADNA pour les non
inscrit bonjour monsieur le Président
Paro monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames Messieurs mes chers collègues
j'avais pas du tout prévu d'intervenir
dans ce débat et puis en regardant
monsieur le ministre les réactions à la
rencontre qu'il y a eu récemment entre
le premier ministres et les
représentants des départements et le
fait qu'il serait éventuellement proposé
au département
difficulté de recevoir des avances je me
suis dit faut quand même que j'aille
dire quelque chose quoi parce que ça
correspond pas vraiment à un notre
problème parce que si les départements
qui sont dans le rouge reçoivent des
avances remboursables ah bah ça va pas
être facile à solutionner quoi et donc
je c'est ce qui m'a fait m'inscrire et
puis d'un autre côté je découvre le
rapport et je vois que finalement
c'était pas vraiment le débat alors tant
pis je vais quand même vous dire ce que
j'en
pense
je crois que la mutualisation n'est pas
à la hauteur du problème qui nous est
posé monsieur le
ministre j'avais conseil général de
l'Aube 39 millions d'autofinancement en
2009 27 millions en
2010 l'augmentation des dépenses
obligatoires dans le domaine social
seulement sur les trois allocations
personnalisées c'est entre 10 et 12
millions d'évolution
annuelle dans 2 ans il n'y a plus
d'autofinancement il n'y a plus de
capacité à rembourser le capital des
emprunts donc toutes les questions qu'on
est en train d'évoquer là ne servent à
rien si nous n'avons pas trouver de
solution à cette problématique à cette
équation impossible c'est-à-dire que
vous nous proposez dans les 3 années qui
viennent de geler les dotations après
nous avoir supprimé nos ressources
fiscales les avoir remplacé par des
dotations et nous dire vous avez des
dépenses obligatoires qui vont continuer
de croître et vous allez pas avoir
d'évolution de vos dotations toutes ces
questions sont un peu inutiles il n'y
aura plus
d'existence de la part des départements
et après avoir fait un plan de relance
en 2009 et ben je vais vous dire que ce
qui va se passer en 2010 en 2011 c'est
qu'il va y avoir suppression des
investissements pas seulement des
départements mais des communes à qui on
donne des subventions moi-même j'ai
réuni mon conseil général cette semaine
devant la gravité de la situation et
nous allons envisager un de réduire
nous-mêmes nos investissements
c'est-à-dire qu'au lieu de faire 80
millions d'euros d'investissement annuel
on va peut-être en faire 40 mais
naturellement on va aussi supprimer les
financements des communes qui au lieu de
faire leurs investissements vont les
supprimer donc vous allez assister d'une
manière mécanique à au contraire du plan
de relance c'est-à-dire un plan
de de de fin de tout investissement je
voulais vous le redire et c'est
l'essentiellement pour ça que j'étais
monté à cette tribune puis j'ai regardé
les les différents documents alors moi
je me suis rendu compte que je faisais
déjà de la mutualisation sans jamais me
poser de question et sans jamais avoir
eu de problème et je me demande bien
pourquoi vous remettez sur la table
finalement des trucs des problèmes qui
n'existe pas alors par exemple euh bah
oui on gère déjà avec les régions par
exemple quand on a un lycée et un
collège qui sont dans le même
établissement on le gère déjà ensemble
on s'est jamais posé de questions on a
pas de problème pour gérer les toos on
le fait ensemble on investit ensemble et
et on gère les dépenses de
fonctionnement ensemble et il y a jamais
eu de problème le et ben chez nous le 10
c'est clair il y a pas de service du
patrimoine il y a pas de service
informatique c'est les services du
conseil général qui le font sans jamais
avoir poser de problème à personne et
même je je trouve des choses amusantes
parce que je vois par de proposition
numéro 5 page 94 que vous dites le
Conseil général si éventuellement les 10
n'accepte pas de recourir à des formule
de mutualisation il va pouvoir supprimer
ses subventions mais le 10 il est
présidé obligatoirement par le conseil
général par le président ou son
représentant alors et et de toute façon
toute dépense nouvelle d' 10 c'est
nécessairement le conseill général qui
finance pas les communes c'est que le
Conseil Général qui finance les dépenses
nouvelles et donc on est en train de
poser des questions qui n'existe pas
donc je voudrais pas que des textes
nouveaux en fait fassent surgir des
problèmes là où il y en a pas et la
mutualisation elle fonctionne déjà il
suffit de la faire je je j'ai vu par
exemple on dit il pourrait y avoir des
des des gestions communes de bâtiments
qui appartiennent au Conseil Général
pour accueillir des services de l'État
mais oui on peut déjà louer en toute
liberté si on a un bâtiment et qu'on
veut accueillir un no service qui qui
soit de l'état d'une autre collectivité
on peut déjà faire une location sans
aucun problème et on gère donc je je
voudrais pas qu'on laisse à croire que
1 la mutualisation entre collectivité
est de nature à résoudre le problème qui
nous est poser c'est l'incapacité que
nous allons avoir extrêmement rapidement
de gérer une équation impossible qui
consiste à nous bloquer les recettes et
à nous laisser continuer à courir des
dépenses obligatoires
explosive ça ne peut pas être réglé par
ce genre de solution et par ailleurs je
voudrais surtout qu'il n'y ait pas de
complexité
nouvelle pour des pratiques qu'on fait
déjà et qui n'ont jamais posé de
problème à personne je vous remercie de
m'avoir
écouté merci Monsieur Hann maintenant la
parole est à Monsieur Alain Duffo pour
le groupe
UMP bonjour bonjour
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs mes
chers
collègues c'est vrai que depuis les
premières lois de décentralisation de
1982 l'évolution voire l'inflation
législative et normative relative au
collectivité territoriale n'est jamais
ne s'est jamais arrêté il est loin en
effet le temps du triptique état
département commune qui était si facile
à comprendre pour nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui la multiplicité des acteurs
et des collectivités territoriales n'
dégal que les attentes portées par les
Français sur les pouvoirs publics car
par temps de crise la puissance publique
est toujours la plus
sollicitée et la spécialisation
thématique des différentes différents
échelons qui s'est dessiné au cours de
ces 30 dernières années de ces
malheureusement pas toujours accompagné
d'une évolution pérenne du financement
des collectivités territoriales et d'une
optimisation de leurs
moyens c'est vrai que la réforme des
collectivités territoriales qui est
menée actuellement par le gouvernement
et plus largement la réflexion sur la
pérennité du fonctionnement
institutionnel actuel nous oblige à
prendre en compte les moyens d'évolu à
chaque
échelon élu conseiller général depuis
maintenant bientôt 30 ans et
vice-président délégué de l'Union des
conseillers généraux de France le CGF
l'essentiel mon intervention portera
donc surtout sur les
départements à mon sens les plus
fragilisés par rapport aux incertitudes
qui pèsent sur le financement de leurs
trois allocations universelles et de
solidarité
l'APA le PCH et le RSA et aussi le poid
le plus en plus significatif de la prise
en charge de la
dépendance si on ajoute à ces facteurs
l'incidence sur la fiscalité de la crise
économique illustré en particulier par
la chute vertigineuse des droits de
mutation et bien c'est vrai la situation
financière des départements est
préoccupante et je rejoins cela ce que
disait à l'instant Philippe ADNA
d'ailleurs les difficulté rencontré par
certains pour boucler leur budget 2010
est symptomatique de la situation
actuelle si les charge de fonctionnement
lié à l'augmentation du nombre de
fonctionnaires territoriaux hors
transfert de compétences et pour
beaucoup dans les difficultés de
certaines de ces collectivités ne faut
pas s'en cacher il n'en demeure pas
moins que les nouvelles charges sociales
pèsent de plus en plus lourd sur les
budgets
départementaux à ce sujet le rapport
jamais a identifié quatre critères
pertinents de fragilité des finances
départementales d'abord en premiereu la
part importante des plus de 75 ans dans
la population départementale et
heureusement elle ne peut que progresser
le taux de chômage bien sûr le revenu
des ménages et enfin la densité de la
population il a également soulever de
nombreuses contraintes que subissent les
conseils généraux et qui leur sont
parfois extérieures des normalisations
excessive outil ou référentiel non
adapté difficulté de communication ou de
diffusion d'information avec leurs
partenaires institutionnel et cetera il
conviendra donc de traiter dans les
meilleurs ces sujets afin d'améliorer
l'action publique locale et de réaliser
là aussi des économies d'échelle d'ors
et déjà le rapport de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales et à la
décentralisation trace effectivement des
pistes
intéressantes je tiens d'ailleurs à
souligner l'excellent travail de nos
quatre collègues rapporteurs le
président Alain Lambert destig Jacques
mzard et Bruno Sid qui n'est pas là ce
dernier Monsieur le Président
effectivement c'est plus
particulièrement penché sur
l'optimisation des moyens des
départements et on le comprend par
rapport aux responsabilités
importantes qu'il occupe à la
DF à cet égard la voie de la
mutualisation telle qu'elle est
préconisée par ce rapport doit être
approfondie car elle permet c'est
certain de dégager des marges de
manœuvre qui sont à mon sens
importantes certains conseils généraux
ça a déjà été dit ont d'ors et déjà mis
en place de telles démarches par voie
conventionnelle comme par exemple dans
le domaine de la gestion des agents
techniciens et au ruers spécialisés mais
je crois que beaucoup d'autres pistes
sont envisageables notamment ce qui
concerne la restauration scolaire par
exemple ou la gestion des bâtiments
collèges les cités mixes à raison encore
beaucoup plus évidente puisque dans
quelques temps ce seront les mêmes élus
qui vont gérer les les équipements des
cés mixtes je me réjouis par ailleurs
que face aux graves difficultés de nos
départements le Premier ministre a
récemment annoncé qu'une aide
exceptionnelle pourra être versée desè
septembre département ne parvennant pas
à boucler leur budget 2010 je crois
qu'ils sont une une dizaine à peu près
dans le cadre d'un contrat de
stabilisation qui fixera malgré tout des
objectifs au département
bénéficiire le Premier ministre François
Fillon a en outre annoncé officiellement
l'ouverture d septembre du chantier de
la dépendance avec une réforme complète
du financement de la PA précisant que la
loi serait votée avant la fin 2010 pour
un système qui devrait être opérationnel
dès l'année 2011 et c'est vrai que les
présidents des conseils généraux avaient
formulé le vœux d'une mise en place
rapide contenu du différentiel entre
ressources transférées et dépenses
constatées qui s'élève à plus de 3
milliards d'euros en défaveur des
département et qui s'aggrave bien sûr
considérablement d'année en année du
fait du vieillissement des populations
et sans attendre septembre les
département pourrait constituer dans les
meilleurs délaiis un groupe de travail
mettant à profit leur expérience de la
gestion de la PA pour préparer ce
rendez-vous et leucgf bien sûr est prête
à s'y
asscier le Premier ministre a également
confirmé l'annonce du président de la
République sur un moratoire immédiate
des normes ayant des conséquences
financières pour toutes les
collectivités locales et c'est
absolument
nécessaire enfin sur la péréquation il
faut se réjouir de l'annonce d'une
réforme
importante des dotations et de la
confirmation de la mise en place d'un
nouveau système de péréquation alimenté
par les droits de mutation et par la
cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises dont le dynamisme devrait
être supérieur à celui de la TP de plus
le gouvernement a laissé ouverte ça
c'est intéressant la possibilité pour
les départements de pouvoir ir
bénéficier des fonds de péréquation
accordés aujourd'hui à une autre
catégorie de collectivité
territoriale toutes ces mesures mes
chers collègues ont été arrêtées à
l'occasion de la rencontre de l'ADF avec
le Premier ministre je crois que c'était
le 1er juin
elles vont incontestablement dans le bon
sens et devrait permettre à la fois le
redressement des départements qui sont
fragilisés mais surtout favoriser une
meilleure homogénéisation des
départements notamment du point de vue
de leur potentialité
fiscale mais est-ce qu'un système de
péréquation sera suffisant est-ce qu'un
système de mutualisation sera
suffisant cela est loin d'être certain
lorsqu'on constate pour les départements
en particulier budget après budget la
baisse et quelquefois la disparition de
l'épargne disponible des départements
concomitemment un endettement qui est de
plus en plus marqué il faudra donc
incontestablement trou sur le moyen
terme des solutions à la fois
structurelles et pérenes et pour y
parvenir je crois que la concertation
entre le gouvernement et les
associations représentatives des
départements des collectivités
territoriales en général et puisque
jamais
nécessaire si un groupe de travail sur
la gestion de la PA est envisagé
l'ouverture du chantier de la dépendance
prévue en septembre devra lui aussi se
préparer dans la concentration la plus
totale et aboutir à des solutions de
financement à la fois pérennes et
consensuelles dans la perspective de
l'application définitive de la réforme
des collectivités territoriales à
l'horizon
2014 je crois et ça sera ma conclusion
qu'il est impératif que nos
collectivités mais en particulier nos
départements retrouvent une stabilité
fiscale et financière si l'on veut
préserver leur mission essentielle de
solidarité et de proximité de nos
territoires notre groupe le groupe um
soutiendra bien sûr les travaux de la
délégation aux collectivités
territoriales et à la décentralisation
qui iront dans ce sens je vous
remercie merci chers collègues
maintenant la parole est à Madame
Jacqueline gourau pour l'Union centriste
elle dispose de 10
minutes
merci
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le
Président j'ai été très intéressé par le
rapport qui a été fait par Monsieur
Lambert destges mzard et sidau et je
voudrais leur adresser mes félicitation
parce que il est utile évidemment à tout
élu local
je dirais que ce
rapport est le bienvenu puisqu'il
s'inscrit dans un
contexte où plusieurs paramètres doivent
être rappelés d'abord le contexte
financier de finances publiques je
dirais de crise des finances publiques
et
naturellement on sait que les col
ctivité local auront de plus en plus de
mal à trouver des
financements et donc la
nécessité de gérer au mieux les
collectivités locales et bien sont
absolument nécessaires ou est absolument
nécessaire et donc la mutualisation est
un des outils bien sûr pour essayer de
gérer au mieux les finances publiques
deuxème point du
contexte c'est que on a trop souvent
entendu dire encore assez récemment même
si ça s'est calmé que les collectivités
locales étaient trop
dépensières alors je voudrais dire que
quand on regarde les
chiffres qui ont été publiés soit par
l'Association des maires de France ou la
DCF et bien on s'aperçoit que 39 % des
intercommunalités pratiquent la
mutualisation
alors dans le rapport il est dit que
c'est encore insuffisant certes mais
c'est déjà pas mal puisque
l'intercommunalité est tout de même un
phénomène qui s'est développé
récemment puisque c'est surtout la loi
Chevenement de la fin des années 90 qui
a je dirais multiplié est les
intercommunalités et donc le fait que
déjà 40 % en gros des communautés se soi
engagé à des degrés divers c'est vrai
dans des partages de services c'est pas
si mal que cela et je trouve bien sûr
qu'il faut les développer mais je
voulais souligner ce
point trisème point de
contexte c'est bien sûr les nouvelles
missions qui sont données aux
collectivités locales soit du fait de la
décentralisation soit du fait
d'apparition je dirais de nouveaux
services par
exemple je prends l'exemple dans le
monde rural qu'on connaît bien c'est le
Spank le service public d'assainissement
non collectif et c'est un des exemples
où la mutualisation c'est rapidement
mise en place parce que une communauté
rurale souvent ne supporait pas à elle
seule l' gauche de quelqu'un pour
s'occuper du Spank et souvent il y a eu
mutualisation sur plusieurs communautés
rurale donc je crois que la
mutualisation est aussi une réponse à
des services nouveaux que l'on apporte à
la
population autre point qui me semble
important qui a déjà été souligné mais
je voulais le dire c'est bien sûr le
fait qu'il y a
recul des services de l'État auprès des
collectivités territoriales alors je le
dis parce que c'est une
réalité par exemple prenons l'exemple
des ex direction départementale de
l'équipement qui jouaient un rôle très
important auprès des communes rurales et
il faut bien reconnaître qu'elles ell
ont beaucoup reculé dans ce domaine et
que par exemple on voit se
profiler les difficultés d'instruction
des permis de
construire dans les DDE où le personnel
se réduit et où donc c'est une charge
qui bien sûr va
incomber aux collectivités territoriales
en particulier aux communes et aux
intercommunalités et là encore on sait
bien que la mutualisation est quelque
chose d'absolument
impératif parce que ça n'est pas
toujours à l'échelle d'une commune mais
souvent à l'échelle de
l'intercommunalité que pourra être
traité ce sujet de
mutualisation bien entendu il faut
ajouter que nous débattons au
moment de ce dossier au moment où nous
débattons au Sénat de la réforme des
collectivités territoriales et je dirais
que ce rapport est donc
d'opportunité je m'arrêterai sur
l'aspect intercommunal pour souligner en
effet que mutualisation et
intercommunalité sont des notions comme
le dit le rapport
siamoise et je pense que il faut
continuer à aider les communes et les
intercommunalités à
développer la mutualisation alors chacun
sait que il y a la mutualisation dite
descendante c'est-à-dire les moyens de
l'Inter communalités qui sont mises au
service des communes et celle qui est
ascendante c'est-à-dire ce sont les
communes qui contribue par la mise à
disposition de leur moyens au plein
succès d'une entreprise
d'intercommunalité donc on sait que
maintenant ce problème est réglé puisque
pendant un certain temps il y avait des
difficultés dans un sens et pas dans
l'autre ce problème étant réglé je pense
que il faut bien prendre conscience que
dans dans les
intercommunalités c'est très important
parce que c'est très pragmatique que de
mettre dans certaines compétences des
services ascendants et dans d'autres des
services descendants pour garantir
l'efficacité la proximité et également
la bonne gestion des services
publics je crois aussi que la
mutualisation et c'est dit dans le
rapport effectivement facilite le
développement de l'esprit et de l'action
intercommunale c'est quelque chose qui
me semble très important déjà
l'intercommunalité en soi favorise je
dirais la
meilleure compréhension pardon des élus
entre eux bien euh des a priori bien euh
des comment dire des
incompréhensions se sont euh comment
dire amoindr euh du fait que les gens
apprennent à travailler ensemble et
finalement ils se disent bah tiens euh
on ait mêmes soucis les mêmes problèmes
et puis tiens je pensais que celui-ci
était plus sectaire ou je ne sais quoi
et finalement les gens en travaillé
ensemble et bien s'aperçoit qu'ils ont
beaucoup plus de points
communs qu'ils ne le pensaient
auparavant alors la mutualisation bien
sûr favorise cela encore
et par l'expérience que j'en
ai c'est très important dans une
intercommunalité même dans les relations
même si les services ne sont pas
actualiser par exemple d'organiser très
régulièrement des réunions de tous les
DGS des mairies qui travaillent entre
elles au sein de
l'intercommunalité c'est-à-dire ne pas
se contenter n'est-ce pas de travailler
avec les services de l'intercommunalité
mais je dirais créer des relations
permanentes aussi avec les DGS des
mairies et je pense que c'est ainsi que
se développera d'autant mieux le
l'action et l'esprit intercommunal bon
j'ai été très intéressé par certaines de
vos propositions en particulier la
proposition numéro 3 pour permettre aux
communes membres d'un mêmeepci d'avoir
des agents communs pour l'exercice de le
mission de service public dont la
compétence n'a pas été transférée ça
prolonge ce que je viens de
dire bien sûr également créer un
coefficient d'intégration
fonctionnelle calculer en
fonction bah je dirais des services qui
ont été mutualisés je voudrais
rappeler que cette idée d'instituer un
dispositif de bonus malus selon le degré
de mutualisation avait été émis par
notre collègue Philippe Dalier dans son
rapport d'octobre 2006 qu'il avait fait
au nom de
l'Observatoire sénatorial de la
décentralisation et euh il disait
introduire dans le calcul de la DGF des
EPCI à fiscalité propre un nouveau
critère appelé le coefficient
d'intégration fonctionnelle mesurant le
degré de mutualisation des services
entre le PCI et ses communes mbres alors
évidemment il s'agissait à enveloppe
constante monsieur le ministre hein euh
et non pas de faire des des dépenses
supplémentaires puisque naturellement
c'était un bonus malus bien
évidemment autre proposition
c'est le principe d'un débat annuel
d'orientation budgétaire entre les
responsables de le PCI et ceux des
communes membres soit inscrit à l'ordre
du jour d'un examen d'un d'un schéma de
mutualisation des services je trouve ça
très intéressant et je dirait que c'est
d'autant plus
intéressant que je crois que les
communes doivent faire un effort d'abord
aussi sur je dirais la
discussion des
budgets à l'intérieur de
l'intercommunalité aujourd'hui il est
impossible d'imaginer que les budgets
communaux soient votés sans qu'il y ait
un minimum de concertation avec
l'intercommunalité des commune membres
ça ça me semble quelque chose de de de
très important même si chacun reste
maître chez soi je dirais c'est
peut-être un peu comme le budget de la
France et ceux des pays européens c'est
quelque chose de un peu similaire le
président me fait signe qu'il faut que
j'accélère je j'ai dépassé al je pose
trois questions euh trois questions au
rapporteur et à Monsieur le Ministre ne
voudrait-il pas aussi essayer de
favoriser la coopération horizontale qui
mériterait d'être
développer 2è
question les groupements de commande ex
existe et je crois qu'il faudrait
légiférer ou réglementer pour que ce
soit plus souple et notamment certains
voudraient aller jusqu'à ce qu'on
appelle des centrales d'achat je pose la
question et enfin et bien il est utile
comme l'a dit mon collègue tout à
l'heure de définir la notion
communautaire de service non économique
d'intérêt général car sinon évidemment
ce sera un frein à la mutualisation je
vous
remercie merci excusez-moi
maintenant nous allons entendre notre
collègue François Fortassin pour le
groupe RDSE il dispose de 8
minutes pas une de
plus nous avonsoir à
1h je suis désoléess de
tenir monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues depuis de nombreuses années
les activités sont confronté à des défis
de plus en plus lourds qu'elles peinent
à satisfaire plusieurs raisons à ce
phénomène les dernières lois de
décentralisation n'ont pas permis le
transfert de moyens nécessair à
l'accomplissement des charges toujours
plus importantes le désengagement de
l'État force de constater qu'il s'est
accentué tant pour des raisons
budgétaires que pour des raisons de
politique nationales qui consiste à
faire peser sur les collectivités ce que
l'État ne peut plus ou ne veut plus
assumer à savoir un éventail toujours
plus large de service de prestation à
fournir pour répondre aux besoins et aux
attentes de nos concitoyens et ce dans
des
secteurs particulièrement coûteux ce
désengagement de l'État contraint
souvent les collectivité à se substituer
à
lui il y a aussi une évaporation des
services déconcentrés de l'État qui nous
oblige souvent à intervenir à sa place
cela s traduit par une augmentation très
forte des dépenses de l'ordre de 100
milliards par an qui ne cesse de croître
et c'est depuis le première loi de
décentralisation ces dépenses ont
progressé plus rapidement que le produit
intérieur brut hors transfert de
compétenence et avec des modification si
on peut dire une forte croissance entre
80 et
91 de l'ordre 3 et dem % par an un
ralentissement de 91 à 98 et puis dans
les 10 dernières années à nouveau une
augmentation faut rappeler que les
collectivités sont des lieux communs que
les collectivités locales sont les
principales contributies de
l'investissement public et qu'ell
consacre 20 % de leurs dépenses voire
plus aux investissements
je ne balaye pas ici l'ensemble de ses
investissements cela bien entendu s'est
traduit face à un certain désengagement
de l'État aussi par des des impôts
locaux qui ont connu une croissance
forte c'est-à-dire que entre 82 et
2008 le poids dans le produit intérieur
brut est de est passé de 3,6 à 5,8 au
niveau des recettes des collectivités
locales cette situation est relativement
donc déséquilibrée et la fiscalité
directe en plus représente de moins en
moins
d'importance la moitié pratiquement des
recettes vient maintenant des transferts
des budgets de l'État ce qui quelque
part est relativement malsin dans la
mesure où se défait le lien entre les
recettes locales et les ces mêmes
dépenses locales certains experts
d'ailleurs nous disent que ces impôts
locaux sont souvent peu lisibles
économiquement inefficaces et voire ça
c'est je crois accepté par tous
socialement injuste mais au
fond il y a des problèmes financiers
c'est évident il faut pas les nier mais
parmi les problèmes
peut-être les plus
important c'est et nous sommes nous
responsables aussi législateurs comme
l'état l' sur bien des points c'est un
certain nombre de législation et
d'empilement de normes qui ont pour
conséquence d'accentuer les recettes et
je prendrai quelques exemples la loi que
je considère comme étant quasi
célérate sur le principe de précaution a
eu pour
conséquence d'AC néfaste d'accentuer les
dépenses d'accentuer du même coup les
exigences de
concitoyens et la surexposition des élus
face à l'appareil judiciaire
on aurait très bien pu se passer de
cette loi que personne ne demandait au
demeurant autre point l'empilement des
normes quelquefois on va même au-delà
dans un
Zè
extrême au-delà de ce que préconise
l'Europe c'est ainsi par exemple que on
fait détruire un péiduve un agriculteur
parce que la profondeur était de 8 cm
alors qu'elle doitre de
10 ça paraît quand même relativement
abérrant mais quelquefois ces choses-là
se grâce à l'intelligence territoriale
qu'a évoqué mon ami Jacques mzard cela
se traduit par quelques ennuis mais les
tracasseries svaporent mais d'autrees
fois c'est pas le cas et
enfin je voudrais prendre en
exemple un service qui s'appelle
l'ONEMA c'est-à-dire l'Office national
des eaux et des milieux aquatiques où on
voit un certain nombre de cerbèes
galonnés et
armés sillonn nos campagnes et qui font
passer les élus locaux pour des
délinquants parce que à tel moment on
aura peut-être quelque peu perturbé le
rythme de reproduction des crapaau
àoucheur
ou de quelque autre espèce salamandre et
vous je présente ça de manière peut-être
un peu amusée mais c'est une réalité
c'est une réalité et puis il faut bien
dire que dans notre pays s'il y a une
solidarité
sociale qui est exemplaire à
certainement sur le plan mondial la
solidarité territoriale et au-delà
d'ailleurs des clivages politiques
elle reste non pas inventée mais elle
peut largement progresser parce que
cette solidarité territoriale
elle reste encore largement
embryonnaire et dans la péréquation que
tout le monde appelle de ses vœux il y a
je crois un grand principe qu'il faut
mettre en avant c'est de dire qu'il faut
apporter un peu plus à ceux qui ont
moins c'est
simple simplement il faudra toucher
incontestablement au pactol qu'un
certain nombre il faut bien dire de nos
collègues de collectivité n'entendent
pas abandonner lorsqu'il le
possède et nous demandons à
l'état d'être au fond le
garant d'une solidarité territoriale et
d'un
développement harmonieux et
équilibré de notre territoire national
de la même façon les fonds européens
pendant longtemps ont servi à cela il
faut bien dire que quelque chose sur un
plan intellectuel qui est les pôles
d'excellence quel personne ne peut être
contre mais ils se sont beaucoup plus
développés il faut bien dire dans les
zones comme la beige dans la région
toulousaine qu'à berberérus lias
charmand patelin qui est au sud de
lourde mais ou incontestablement il y a
peu de chance qu'il yit un jour un pôle
d'excellence et c'est tout à fait norm
avir un miracle peut certes y avoir un
miracle monsieur le Président je crois
que je n'ai pas tout à fait épuisé le
temps de parole
mais j'en en terminer
merci maintenant la parole est à
collègue René
Vestri faudrait peut-être que l'on
propose au sénateur Fortassin de faire
une proposition de loi pour mettre les
parlementaires parmi les espèces protégé
à
venir monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
comme Monsieur Jourdain faisait de la
prose sans le savoir j'ai pratiqué la
mutualisation sans m'en rendre compte
des décennies durant à la tête de
structures communales ou
intercommunal encore que comme l'indique
le rapport de nos collègues destges et
mard consacré à
l'intercommunalité
curieusement aucun des termes
intercommunalité ou intercommunal et
mutualisation qui figure à de si
nombreuses reprises dans nos textes
législatif et réglementairire n'a
aujourd'hui reçu l'onction de l'Académie
française
aussi je voudrais dire un mot sur la
muttilisation hors Communauté de
Communes d'agglomération ou
urbaine d'emblé j'apporte une précision
maire d'une petite commune de 2000
habitants élu d'un canton de 6 communes
de 22000 habitants au total depuis plus
de 25 ans ma laattitude à pratiquer la
mutualisation a été plus grande sans
doute que dans de grandes
collectivités bien avant que l'on ne
contraigne certaines communes au
regroupement dans des EPCI qui les
éloignent de la réalité du
terrain la principale raison du succès
de certaines actions mutualistes d'avant
le regroupement au sein des communautés
de communes je la vois dans la
motivation des élus et des
agents l'implication des personnels
attaché à leur village et terroir et
certainement aussi un gage de réussite
car ils se sentent davantage concerné et
l'esprit de chapelle est moins présent
qu'on ne le pense habituellement
depuis plus de 20 ans avec mes collègues
maires du canton nous avons en effet mis
en commun des moyens financiers des
biens immobiliers et du personnel de nos
établissements respectifs afin de gérer
au mieux nos budgets de réaliser des
économies de pratiquer des synergies et
de générer des financements croisés plus
faciles à obtenir de la part de l'État
et de la région du département voire de
l'Europe quand on est plusieurs à les
demander je m'enorgueilliis avec des
maires de mon canton de certains
résultats positifs mais j'ai aussi connu
quelques
désillusions ainsi les communes membres
ont profité soit dans leur budget soit
dans les services offerts à la
population des avantages procurés par
les économies généré
ou les moyens supplémentaires dégagés ou
mis en œuvre avant les regroupements
forcés dans les nouvelles structure créé
aujourd'hui cette mutualisation qui a
permis par exemple de faire sur des
terrains mitoyens à deux communes l'un
des plus beaux stades de mon département
géré de manière souple et efficace avec
une simple
convention avec la commune voisine
rencontre ses limites dès lors qu'il
faudra désormais utiliser l'espace
public autrement que par une simple mise
à disposition à des
associations mais cette mutualisation
existe depuis 70 ans nous n'avons rien
inventé nos prédécesseurs par
pragmatisme et sans souciis de
formalisme superflu se donner les moyens
de faire
efficacement leur efficacité devait
aussi quelque chose au fait qu'il se
posait moins de questions que les élus
n'étaient pas suspecté par avance de
tout et de rien il y avait un certain
laisser faire et même laisser aller cher
physiocrate amené par Monsieur ducenet
qui rapportait à la gestion de la chose
publique rappelez-vous ce que disait ce
bon
Duquenet philosophe économiste du temps
des
lumières les prohibitions restreignent
le travail les taxes le renchérissent et
le surchargent les privilèges exclusifs
le font dégénérer en monopole onéreux et
destructeur il ne faut donc sur ce
travail ni prohibition ni taxes ni
privilèg
excessifs je vous propose de vous en
inspirer pour laisser aux collectivités
quel que soit leur taille cette liberté
de s'associer pour mutualiser les moyens
qu'ell jugent util sans plus de
formalisme l'inconvénient de réussir une
mutualisation par contre on la ressent
parfois lorsqu'on demande des moyens
complémentaires en effet on se les voit
refuser au prétexte que nous avons su
dégager des excéd d'argent et de
moyens je vois donc dans la
mutualisation une incitation à la vertu
et à la coopération mais j'y vois aussi
une possibilité offerte à moins
d'engagement des collectivités
d'échelons supérieurs à commencé par
l'État pour les petites communes la
pratique mutualiste n'est donc pas
récompensée j'ai lu avec attention les
dispositif proposés par les rapporteurs
il y a néanmoins deux objections que je
voudrais faire valoir d'une part dans
les EPCI communautaires ce sera toujours
la plus grande collectivité qui prendra
l'initiative d'autre part ce sera
toujours la grande collectivité qui
bénéficiera des dotations obtenu par
simple effet mécanique des
pourcentages c'est la raison pour
laquelle en débat d'orientation un débat
d'orientation budgétaire annuelle entre
les responsables des EPCI et l'ensemble
des communes mesure proposé par nos
collègues dans ce rapport est une idée
que je vous demande de retenir et de
proposer dans un prochain texte sur la
réforme des collectivités
territoriales je voudrais m'attarder un
moment sur les
10 selon les dispositions de l'article l
1424 3 et 4 du CGCT les 10 sont placés
pour emploi sous l'autorité du maire et
du préfet agissant dans le cadre de leur
pouvoir respectif de police pourtant
messieur George Ginesta des rosier et
Thierry Mariani ont noté dans un récent
rapport on peut se demander s'il faut
continuer à enclure la sécurité civile
dans la compétence du maire et du préfet
en matière de police alors que les 10
sont désormais financés majoritairement
par les conseils généraux ce constat est
largement partagé par les membres de la
délégation comme la rappeler votre
rapporteur lors de la réunion du 25 mai
2010 les missions des10 en matière
d'incendie et de secours relève de
l'État tandis que leur financement
provient en majorité des départements
c'est la raison pour laquelle votre
rapporteur souhaite que soit clarifié le
statut des 10 et leur relations avec
l'État et les département mes chers
collègues là encore mutualisation ne
signifie pas raison encore moins
efficacité aujourd'hui les 10 sont
présidés par les élus conseillers
généraux demain le seront-il par des
conseillers territoriaux les 10 sont
abondés par les
collectivités l'État et majoritairement
par les conseils généraux à hauteur de
54 % tout cela est bien mais qui est en
charge de par la loi de l'emploi des1 au
titre des pouvoirs de police est-ce le
préfet et le maire d'après l'article
14243 du CGCT comme l'indique le rapport
s'il y a rationalisation des moyens par
le financement il y a une mutualisation
qui n'est pas évidente en ce qui
concerne le endement et l'engagement des
moyens sur le terrain souvent éloignés
des lieux de sinistre ou de
prévention ne pourrait-on pas avec la
réforme des collectivités territoriales
décider une fois pour toutes de faire
des 10 des directions départementales
placé sous l'autorité du Préfet et du
maire cette réforme dirait que les 10
s'équipe s'entraînent et se gère sous la
responsabilité du président du conseil
général et qu'ils agissent de manière
opérationnelle sous la direction du
Préfet et du
maire une telle organisation
simplifierait la compréhension
l'organisation et la gestion des 10
devenu des directions départementales de
secours et de lutte contre les
incendies par ailleurs les activités
portuaires des communes du littoral
pourrai être Mutu
au sein d'une structure propre à ces
communes sans autre souci que de laisser
faire des gens qui savent gérer leurs
installations au profit des
usagers sans aller jusqu'à transférer
des compétences à des EPCI qui pour
certains ont plus de superficie
montagneus à gérer que de littoral à
administrer dans tous les cas de figure
une mutualisation réussie etgage
d'économie et de saine gestion il
faudrait donc pour inciter les
collectivités à la pratiquer mettre en
place des moyens incitatifs par exemple
bonifier les excédents placés à la suite
d'économie dû à cette
mutualisation pourquoi ne pas inviter
les organismes auprès desquels les
collectivé place leurs excédents à
majorit à majoré pardon les placements
excédentaires sous avis conforme des
services placés sous l'autorité des
trésoriers payeurs
départementaux mais parfois il faut
aussi y avoir y
voir non pas des économies mais des
synergies donc des solidarités qui se
mettent en place cet état d'esprit
favorable à une meilleure prise en
compte des besoins des contribuables et
usagés doit être encouragé par une
simplification des structures de
coopération ou par un toilettage des
textes qui permettent cette coopération
je vous remercie de votre
attention merci Monsieur
bestest la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Claude berb pour le groupe
socialiste
président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues je ne peux démarrer mon
intervention sur l'optimisation des
moyens des collectivités locales qui est
dont on consacre le débat ce matin sans
quand même rappeler les les contraintes
dans lequell se trouvent ces
collectivités locales et plus
particulièrement les intercommunalités
puisque je m'exprimerai plutôt dans le
domaine des
intercommunalités je crois que il faut
rappeler aujourd'hui un certain nombre
d'orateurs avant moi l' rappelé mais il
faut quand même le redire avec force
notamment pour les communautés
d'agglomération j'en préside une depuis
un certain nombre d'années la réforme de
la taxe
professionnelle nous a conduit va nous
conduire à moins de recettes fiscales
puisque la TPU était la seule recette
fiscale que nous avions euh le
dispositif qui le remplace est non
seulement moins dynamique mais il nous
éloigne des entreprise et dont il peut
nous éloigner je dirais il peut nous
éloigner de mettre en place des
démarches pour les attirer le deuxième
point c'est que il fait entrer dans la
fiscalité une ligne fiscalité des
ménages que nous n'avions pas jusqu'à
présent et toutes les opérations qui
seront désormais menées par les
communautés d'agglomération et je parle
essentiellement de celle-là seront
également financé par les ménages ce qui
n'était pas le cas dernière jusqu'à
présent le deuxième point c'est les
contraintes dans lequel nous exerçons
nos compétences et dans lequel on nous
incite je dirais à mutualiser ou à
optimiser le fait d'optimiser mutualiser
ce sont deux termes quand même qui qui
sont pas tout à fait pareils dans la
réalit du terrain et dans la réalité je
dirais euh de de de la mise en place de
de cette politique là et je voudrais
revenir sur le désengagement de l'État
un désengagement très très très fort non
seulement à travers de la
RGPP mais également à travers la mise en
place de mesures de non remplacement d'
fonctionnaire sur deux dès le départ à
la retraite qui conduisent les services
réorganisés désormais euh à ne plus
avoir quelquefois de personnes à
proposer euh pour accompagner les
politiques menées par les collectivité
d'une façon générale euh je pense à
l'accompagnement que nous avions en
matière d'urbanisme l'instruction des
permis de construire a été euh je dirais
signalé tout à l'heure mais nous
l'avions de la même façon avec les
maîtrises euh l'accompagnement en
maîtrise à mettre d'ouvrage que nous
avions euh pour l'assaainissement pour
l'au bref nous faisions appel nous
faisions appel à des au services de
l'État qui nous accompagnent dans ces
démarches aujourd'hui ces services
n'existent plus
ou pour certaines communes ils offrent
je dirais des délais d'attente qui
incite un certain nombre de communes à
reprendre à leur compte je dirais les
services qui étaient remplis par l'État
alors on nous dit il faut mutualiser
alors il faut muttiliser oui mais il
faut muttiliser mutual sous la
contrainte et ça va se traduire
obligatoirement par des coûts
supplémentaires parce que ces services
étaient assuré par des fonctionnaires de
l'État deuxièmement je voudrais dire
également que en matière de
mutualisation et ça a été je crois dit
dans le rapport qui dit
mutualisation ne dit pas forcément
moindre coût je crois que les exemples
sont nombreux en tant que président
d'une intercommunalité euh comme
beaucoup d'intercommunalités nous avons
mutualisé je prends le service des
déchets ménagers par exemple bon nous
avions des services qui étit assuré par
les différentes communes la communauté
d'agglomération a pris ce service dont
elle a elle a repris le personnel bon ça
mis un peu un peu de temps le personnel
a d'abord été mis à disposition puis en
fait on a créé un vrai service de
déchets ménagers euh d'une part nous
avons dû euh procéder à des mises à
niveau de matériel un certain nombre de
de commune qui savait que nous allions
transférer la compétence n'avait pas
fait les investissements nécessaires
donc il a fallu investir et ensuite on
s'est retrouvé dans un dispositif où les
citoyens ont demandé plus que les
services qui étaient rendus on est passé
d'une collecte simple de déchets
ménagers à une collecte sélective de
déchets recyclables à une calecte
sélective de déchets verts à la mise en
place de déchetterie bref ça c'est pas
traduit du tout par des économies
d'échelle à partir du moment où nous
avons pris sa compétence et comme l'a
dit for très très fort bien mon collègue
Jacques
mzard la prise de compétenence et
l'aboutissement ultime de la mutisation
dans la réalité au niveau des coûts dans
un premier temps ça coûtait plus cher
aujourd'hui nous sommes arrivés à
mutualiser à faisant baisser les coups
mais je crois qu'il faut le signaler de
façon très forte un contexte d'une part
contraint de et qui est en grande partie
dû à la politique menée par le
gouvernement aujourd'hui et deuxièmement
mutilalisation ne dit pas forcément
réduction de coût alors je voudrais il
me reste quelques minutes remercier
quand même les les rapporteurs sur je
dirais leur leur travail Alain Lambert
Yve de trgne Jacques mzard bruno Sido et
l'apport important de
edmand Hervé qui s'il n'est pas
signataire
a toujours montré euh sa parfaite
connaissance de la des des de
l'intercommunalité et puis des systèmes
de péréquation et et de mutualisation et
euh dans les propositions qui euh qui
nous sont faites proposées je me demande
d'ailleurs si compte tenu de ce que je
viens de dire en avant hein sur sur les
contraintes on sera en mesure de les
mettre en œuvre mais il y en a un
certain nombre qui sont intéressantes et
euh je pense que il faut effectivement
essayer de trouver une sécurisation
juridique comme vous l'avez demandé
monsieur Lambert et euh puisqu'il me
reste que 30 secondes je voudrais
insister sur le fait d'une muttilisation
ascendante prenons le cas et c'est le
cas de ma communauté d'agloot elle a une
compétence qui est l'aménagement des
bords d'une rivière les bords de lîle
don elle a aménagé des pistes cyclables
elle aménagé des jardins en continuité
elle n'a pas pris la la compétence
voirie donc elle a
l'entretien de ces pistes cyclables
pistes piétones et de ces jardins euh
nous souhaitons et on l'a fait mais on
n'est pas tout à fait dans Les Clos nous
souhaitons confier aux communes qui ont
leurs propres servicees d'entretien de
faire pour le compte de la communauté
agglomération ben l'entretien des
espaces que ce soit le balayage
de la de la piste verte de la de la voie
cyclable que ce soit l'entretien et
cetera et cetera on est aujourd'hui on a
on a trouvver un dispositif mais on est
dans l'insécurité juridique alors donc
s'il n'y avait qu'une seule demande
alors elle pourrait s'inscrire dans le
projet de loi qui qui est en train de
que l' en train de discuter c'est de
permettre justement cette
mutualisation remontante puisque sur la
mutualisation descendante on est à peu
près d'accord on arrive à à trouver des
solutions
j'aurai d'autres propositions à faire
mais le temps M compé j'en reste là je
vous remercie de m'avoir
écouté merci Monsieur berb maintenant
nous allons écouter notre collègue
pierreisson pour le groupe
rump monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues tout
d'abord je voudrais
remercier rapporteur parce que je crois
que ce document est d'une inspiration
très intéressante pour aller vers une
évolution
législative qui concerne un sujet
important sur
lequel avec j'allais dire un peu
d'esprit de synthèse on pourrait dire
optimisation
mutualisation le système est-il
perfectible le système est-il
perfectible alors sans sans remonter au
Moyen-Âge mais quand même messieur
rapporteur
interrogation pourquoi une telle
frilosité à l'égard de la mutualisation
les seigneurs qui autant de la féolité
rassemblaient les armées de leur vassau
ne la pratiquaent-il pas déjà l'Union
des communautés villageoises contre le
brigandage n'était-elle pas une forme de
mutualisation j'espère que le brigandage
a disparu mais entendre les propos de
certains de nos collègues sur le les
injustices et les
irrégularités on pourrait peut-être
faire une recherche ADN pour savoir où
se situe euh les brigandages modernes
mais là n'est pas le sujet je voudrais
plus sérieusement dire assurer des
services qu'une collectivité n'a pas ou
plus les moyens d'accomplir seul et
améliorer les services existants je
crois qu'il y a là messieurs les
rapporteurs euh sur ces ces deux points
matière quasiment à faire le chapeau de
optimisation mutualisation et de lui
donner une certaine ambition et un
souffle nouveau et et un peu plus de
cohérence et de cohérence territoriale
alors j'entends parler beaucoup de de
péréquation mais n'y a-t-il pas une
logique quelque part àce que au moins
sur quelques points on aille vers un peu
plus de cohérence territoriale et un peu
plus d'harmonisation fiscale parce que
je prendrai l'exemple de la communauté
d'agglomération d'Any à laquelle
j'appartiens les taux de fiscalité au
moment où la taxe professionnelle qui
était l'impôt unique s'en va et où
forcément il faut ouvrir le débat sur
j'allais dire quelle fiscalité pour
demain pour trouver non seulement les
équilibres mais trouver les moyens
comment faire alors que on va vers une
fiscalité locale à répartir partager
mixte mutualisé comme vous voulez on
l'appelle de de de tous les noms on peut
lui donner tous les qualificatifs mais
dire que comment faire dans une
intercommunalité où la ville centre à un
taux de fiscalité taxe d'habitation et
foncier bâti supérieur à 16 % et comment
certaines communes membres de cette
communauté d'agglomération ont une
fiscalité inférieure à 7 %. là se pose
le premier problème parce que on ne peut
pas lancer le débat ou tout du moins
faire évoluer la péréquation si on ne se
penche pas sur ce problème et essayer de
lui donner les moyens et les obligations
et un peu les contraintes quelque part
en matière de législative normative et
réglementaire pour aller vers
l'harmonisation et avec un objectif de
taux unique je crois que euh c'est vrai
pour un certain nombre de choses alors
on peut le faire par ce
moyen-là et je pense que c'est un des
sujets sur lequel le texte législatif
monsieur le ministre devra se pencher
cette harmonisation en marche avec
forcément euh un calendrier qui permette
qui évite euh les les évolutions trop
rapides les chocs et et bien entendu les
polémiques que cela pourrait engendrer
mais l'autre sujet c'est aussi de
rassembler dans des syndicats mixtes des
collectivités sur une cohérence et une
pertinence d'un périmètre territorial
qui permet de gérer ensemble et
d'optimiser un certain nombre de
services l'eau l'assainissement les
déchets des transports publics de
voyageurs en dehors des agglomérations
qui de par la loi d'orientation des
transports intérieurs d'illeurs
bénéficie d'une autonomie d'organisation
de transport et en relation avec les
départements qui ont reçu cette
compétence mais qui l'organise de
manière avec les moyens possibles de
manière plus ou moins égale
euh selon les territoires ruraux
périurbains et sans aucune souvent sans
aucune relation et sans aucune connexion
suffisante avec les services urbains
organisés vis rappeler monsieur le
ministre c'est le rapporteur que mes
chers collègues que ce qui a fait la
réussite de la Poste dans notre pays et
c'est principalement le tarif unique du
timbre c'est-à-dire que vous écriviez à
votre voisin de palier ou que vous
écriviez à l'autre extrémité du pays
l'affranchissement est de même valeur et
je crois que sur le tarif unique des
services à travers les syndicats mixtes
et à travers les intercommunalités sur
l'harmonisation sur un territoire
cohérent qui a décider de se regrouper
pour son avenir et pour son destin il y
a une logique quelque part
d'harmonisation faut-il encore que les
communes qui ont des taux de fiscalité
bas pour deux motifs principaux un
l'absence de servicees par rapport à ce
qui est apporté par l'agglomération donc
un des deux points importants que vous
avez soulevé la commune qui n'a pas ou
qui n'a plus les moyens d'organiser les
services mais on ne peut pas non plus
écarter l'idée de regarder ceux qui ont
bien géré c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont des
taux de fiscalité parce qu'ils ont été
très attentifs aux dépenses de
fonctionnement parce qu'ils ont
privilégié la investissement dans la
mise en œuvre de leur budget parce
qu'ils sont allés vers des
intercommunalités intelligentes et des
intercommunalité à périmètrre de
cohérence territoriale qui fait que on a
un mélange entre ceux qui avaient de
gros moyens ceux qui avaient de grosses
assiettes fiscales ou ou ou d'assiettes
techniqu le volume d'eau le tonnage des
déchet la densité des transports à
organiser en fonction des transports
scolaires en fonction de l'implantation
des établissements scolaires les
collèges pour les départements et les
lycées pour les régions donc toutes ces
choses-là mérite une analyse qui a déjà
été largement avancée dans ce document
qui a le grand mérite et je terminerai
là-dessus monsieur le Président qui a le
grand mérite de nous éclairer sur un
texte pour l'avenir d'un texte
législatif rendu indispensable par
l'évolution de la fiscalité dû à la
suppression que nous avons soutenu
largement sur ces bans la suppression de
la taxe professionnelle mais qui mérite
d'urgence une organisation et et un
cadre législatif pour cette haronisation
fiscale dont j'ai essayé d'ébaucher ici
quelques lignes je vous
remercie merci Monsieur maintenant la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Luc Fichet
pour le groupe
socialisteonjour
monsieur le ministre messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers
collègues nous ne sommes pas un paradoxe
prêt avec ce gouvernement nous défendons
dans l'hémicycle aujourd'hui grâce au
formidable travail de la délégation
collectivité territoriale l'idée de
développer la mutualisation dans les
politiques territoriales or tout a été
mis en œuvre par le pouvoir actuel pour
que cette mutualisation qui existait
disparaisse il est d'ailleurs
intéressant de comparer les propositions
essentielles faites dans ce rapport pour
améliorer les politiques publiques avec
celle mise en œuvre par le Président de
la République et qui n'ont pour seul
objectif que de réduire à néant ces
mêmes politiques
publiques ce débat ne peut pas être
détaché du contexte dans lequel il a
lieu la vie des collectivités
territoriales est aujourd'hui
bouleversée par les projets du
gouvernement le projet de loi de réforme
des collectivités territoriales est
injuste
recentralisateur et
inefficace j'en reviens au débat qui
nous anime monsieur le rapporteur vous
définissez la mutualisation des moyens
des collectivités territoriales comme
étant la mise en place temporaire ou
pérenne d'une log d'une logistique
commune à deux ou plusieurs
collectivités où est la nouveauté vous
n'inventez rien il nous faut plutôt
dénoncer
la mise à mal des mutualisations
existantes prenons l'exemple de
l'expertise au
collectivités la baisse des services
sans contrepartie je prends l'exemple de
la DDE notamment fait que l'idée de la
mutualisation de l'expertise revient
aujourd'hui sur le devant de la scène en
effet avoir une étude neutre et
impartiale des projets est essentiel
pour la dynamique des collectivités
territoriales et leur bonne gestion
mettre en place des politiques actualis
au service de l'intérêt général tel est
le souhait que nous partageons sur tous
ces bancs cependant comme l'a dit ADM
Hervé de nombreuses collectivités
n'auront pas la capacité de se doter de
certains services experts pour jouer
leur rôle de maîtrise
d'ouvrage malheureusement nous sommes
nous élus locaux confrontés à ce manque
d'expertise neutre et impartiale depuis
que les services d'état ne jouent plus
ce rôle
essentiel je retiendrai donc dans la
proposition de Monsieur de créer entre
les collectivités des services
d'expertise pour venir en aide aux
petites collectivité dans les trois
domaines que sont la
fiscalité l'environnement et
l'urbanisme point positif le projet de
loi de réforme des collectivités
territoriales permet au département de
contribuer au financement des opérations
dont la maîtrise d'ouvrage est assuré
par les communes ou le groupement nous
devons aller plus loin cette expertise
doit être neutre et indépendante je l'ai
souligné elle doit également être
accessible à l'ensemble des
collectivités pour lesqueles
contractualisé de façon récurrente avec
un cabinet de conseil privé représente
un cout important voire
exorbitant il faut donc recréer un
service d'expertise neutre pour assurer
et assister les collectivités je
voudrais ici parler du désarroi des élus
dans le relation avec les entreprises
multinationales avec lesquelles il
sigent des contrats parfois léonins en
l'absence de tiers
objectif les collectivités territoriales
sont sans protection quand les
entreprises viennent se partager le
gâteau sur leur dos on le voit dans nos
communes avec des contrats d'affermage
en matière d'assainissement ou de
gestion de l'eau potable des ordes
ménagères aujourd'hui les collectivités
n comme solution que ces contrats or
elles sont
face aux entreprises concernées qui bien
souvent il faut le dire se sont partagé
le territoire la commune a beau jeu
alors de vouloir faire un nouvel appel
d'offre en cas de renouvellement du
contrat ce n'est pas elle qui au final a
la main sur cette question or la
mutualisation pourrait s'entendre en
terme de régie afin de donner une
véritable alternative aux collectivités
et créer les moyens d'une vraie
concurrence
je me félicite de ce que les rapporteurs
ne voient pas comme objectif principal à
la mutualisation la nécessité de faire
des économies
d'échelle la
mutualisation peut permettre et doit
aider à l'optimisation des coût mais
elle n'est pas la réponse à la crise
financière je souhaiterais dans un
dernier temps égir ma réflexion il
convient de réfléchir à la mutualisation
des moyens autour d'un projet politique
la mutualisation en terme
d'administration territoriale est un
concept très fort ce n'est plus être
chacun les uns à côté des autres mais
bien être tous intéressé par ce que fait
l'autre il s'agit bel et bien d'une
solidarité territoriale c'est ce qui a
été à l'origine de
l'intercommunalité à savoir dépasser la
rivalité entre les communes mais il faut
faire très attention la mutualisation ne
peut pas être un mauvais pensement sur
les manquement de l'État on le voit par
exemple pour la mise en place du haut
débit sur tout le territoire la liaison
numérique est devenue une nécessité de
service public pourtant l'État ne joue
pas son rôle en la matière ainsi dans
les agglomérations attractives les
opérateurs privés se précipitent mais il
n'en est pas de même dans les zones les
plus éloignées
lâché par l'État et par les opérateurs
privés les communes ne peuvent pas
financer seul cette nouvelle charge
c'est alors que la mutualisation se met
en œuvre on le voit par exemple dans le
Finistère avec le projet de haut débit
du
département la mutualisation qui
s'impose par défaut est toujours
regrettable j'estime que la
mutualisation peut-être pour les
responsables des collectivités
territoriales une nouvelle façon de
il s'agit de travailler mieux et au plus
près des besoins il s'agit de donner un
avenir à chacune des collectivités il ne
s'agit pas par exemple pour les communes
périphériques ou éloigné de se défier de
la ville de centre mais plutôt de
prendre les moyens pour mieux travailler
ensemble et faire émerger ce qu'il y a
de plus fort dans chaque entité la
mutualisation doit s'apprécier entre
tous les niveaux de la collectivité
notre réflexion dépasse la seule vision
intercommunale et ne doit pas s'arrêter
au niveau territorial ce débat doit
continuer si le gouvernement nous en
donne les moyens je vous
remercie merci Monsieur ficher
maintenant nous allons entendre monsieur
Claude janerau dernier
intervenant avant les réponses du
ministre
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous sommes
réunis donc pour débattre de
l'optimisation des moyens des
collectivités territoriales je veux
d'abord saluer le travail de la
délégation et je veux rendre hommage à
son président Alain Lambert pour son
engagement
consensuel pour toutes les collectivités
et tout particulièrement pour les
départements ce débat semble en première
analyse en tout cas d'une brûlante et
cruelle
actualité la mutualisation des moyens
certes est une voix nécessaire dans ce
contexte mais elle est loin de
représenter une réponse pour aujourd'hui
permettez-moi mes chers collègues
d'évoquer la situation du département
que je préside le département du dou à
bien des égards j'en ai la conviction
cette situation est emblématique à la
fois des risques et des difficultés que
connaissent nos territoires
départementaux
aujourd'hui jusqu'à l'apparition de la
crise mon département a su faire face
tant bien que mal comme les autres à ses
dépenses obligatoire sur le champ des
solidarités sociales depuis la chute des
recettes et la hausse exponentielle des
dépenses rendent l'équation impossible
pourtant les trois allocations
individuelles
APA PCH RSA dont le versement vous le
savez in comombe au département relève à
l'évidence d'un enjeu de solidarité
essentiel majeur et sans doute préalable
à toutes les autres puisqu'elle
conditionneent le minimum vital des
personnes les plus fragiles c'est
pourquoi chacun s'accorde à reconnaître
le caractère nécessairement national
j'insiste là-dessus de cette solidarité
cette solidarité elle est au fondement
de notre pacte républicain or son
financement repose aujourd'hui de plus
en plus sur les contributions du
contribuable local et puisqu'on veut
évoquer la mutualisation comme piste de
solution le premier devoir de
mutualisation ne serait-il pas
d'organiser au niveau national les
conditions de cette solidarité plutôt
que de la trans
sans moyens correspondant à des
collectivités de plus en plus
exang au-delà du caractère par
définition injuste et inéquitable du
système ce qui est évidemment suffisant
pour le condamner les conséquences vous
le savez sont désastreuses pour les
territoires ces conséquences vous les
connaissez les inégalité se creuse aussi
bien sur le champ social que sur le
champ territorial
il devient de plus en plus difficile
voire impossible d'assurer l'entretien
de nos collèges ou de nos routes et que
dire de nos compétences facultatives qui
pourtant assurent une fonction décisive
au service au service de la cohésion
sociale ou du développement économique
de nos territoires permettez-moi de
l'illustrer rapidement pour ma
collectivité à l'aide de deux chiffres
significatifs le premier
c'est la charge nette pour mon
département en 2009 sur l'ensemble des
trois allocations de solidarité cette
charge est de l'ordre de 55 millions
d'euros depuis 2005 en cumule l'écart
est de 150 millions d'euros c'est-à-dire
l'équivalent de la construction de H
collèges neufs pourtant la
décentralisation avec Jean-Pierre
rafarin semblait avoir franchi une étape
irréversible en gravant dans la
Constitution le principe rappelez-vous
de la compensation à
l'europrê je cite l'article 722 de la
Constitution selon lequel tout transfert
de compétences entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales s'accompagne
de l'attribution de ressources
équivalentes à cell qui était consacré à
à leur
exercice le transfert des compétences
sociales au département vous le savez
s'est affranchi de ce principe
constitutionnel
plus personne aujourd'hui ne conteste la
suixie Financière de nos départements ce
constat dépasse vous l'avez entendu tout
à l'heure les clivage politique pour
faire consensus le président du conseil
général de hauteloire Gérard Roche a
souligné qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'un
combat droitegauche mais d'un combat
contre un état central qui a voté des
lois qu'il est incapable de financer et
comment ne pas être d'accord avec lui
quelles sont les solutions proposées
face à l'asphyie des finances locales la
mutualisation constitue--elle une
réponse à l'évidence non la
mutualisation la plus efficace et la
plus radicale c'est celle qui garantit
outre l'optimisation les conditions de
l'équité et de l'efficacité sociale
c'est-à-dire la péréquation entre les
territoires réalisons d'abord
les conditions de cette justice
préalable il sera bien temps ensuite de
rechercher les voies de progrès en
direction d'une mutualisation plus
effective au service de cette justice de
base je propose à titre de contribution
de voies la première je l'ai exposé elle
passe par une
refonte totale des règles de la
solidarité nationale la seconde mais je
n'aurai pas le temps de vous l'exposer J
endrait si vous le voulez bien dans le
cours du débat elle passe par une
réflexion sur les conséquences de la
suppression de la taxe professionnel
aboutissant à toute aboutissant à une
abolliition pour nos collectivités de
toute autonomie fiscale alors en effet
et j'en viens à ma conclusion mes chers
collègues
oui les voix de la mutualisation
méritent d'être empruntées dès lors
qu'ell permettent optimisation et
efficacité renforcée mais cela n'aura de
sens que si des prérequis sont réalisés
à savoir l'organisation d'une justice
élémentaire dans la répartition des
ressources faute de quoi cette question
de la mutualisation j'en ai la
conviction risque bien de devenir un
leur bien dérisoire et bien inutile je
vous
remercie
merci Monsieur Jean alors Monsieur Ann
Marlec secrétaire d'État à l'intérieur
et collectivité territorial va se faire
un devoir de répondre aux
intervenants bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le le président de la
Délégation aux collectivités
territoriales et à la décentralisation
monsieur le ministre Alain Lambert
monsieur les les les rapporteur donc viv
de tregne Jacques mzard bruno Sido
permettez-moi même si il a dit qu'il
souhaitait pas être rapporteur de citer
le rôle joué par Monsieur le Ministre ad
Hervé alors mesdames et et Messieurs les
les sénateurs l'initiative de de ce
débat est particulièrement heureuse
puisqu'elle situe quelques semaines
après les conclusions de la conférence
sur les déficits publics et quelques
jours avant la 2è lecture par votre
assemblée du projet de loi de réforme
des collectivités territoriales et enfin
quelques jours avant le débat
d'orientation budgétaire ce débat
intervient également dans un contexte
particulier pour nos finances public qui
nécessite un effort partagé dans la
maîtrise de nos dépenses et à l'évidence
la question de l'optimisation des moyens
des collectivités territoriales est
d'une actualité particulière et elle
appelle un éventail de réponses concrète
à cet égard je vous remercie donc pour
l'initiative de ce débat qui va
permettre j'en suis persuadé de
progresser dans ces pistes prometteuses
et j'ai enregistré beaucoup de
propositions positives ce matin et bien
entendu nousous s'efforceront d' tenir
le plus grand compte au niveau du
gouvernement alors j'ai dé délibérément
parlé d'éventail de réponses concrètes
car les moyens des collectivités
territoriales embrassent de multiples
formes qui appelleront des solutions
bien entendu spécifiques et c'est
pourquoi je souhaiterais d'abord évoquer
avec vous la question des ressources
avant d'évoquer la mutualisation sur
laquelle le rapport de votre délégation
apporte une très précieuse contribution
et je le redis encore une fois alors
d'abord et premièrement une réflexion
sur l'optimisation des moyens doit bien
entendu et nécessairement aborder la
question des ressources financières et
je voudrais rappeler très brièvement ici
les apports du groupe de travail mené
par le député Gilles carz et le préfet
Michel Thau sur la maîtrise de la
dépense locale vous le rappelle ils ont
formulé plusieurs conclusions
marquantes premièrement hors
décentralisation les dépenses locales
ont augmenté quand même plus vite que le
Produit Intérieur Brut jusqu'au milieu
des années 90 et par la suite à un
rythme plus proche du PIB deuxièmement
les disparités de dépenses sont
importantes au sein même au sein d'un
d'un même niveau de de collectivité par
exemple le niveau de dépenses par
habitant varie de 1 à 3 entre les 10 %
de communes les moins dépensières et les
10 % les plus dépensières enfin et et
surtout il existe e une forte
corrélation entre le niveau de
ressources d'une collectivité et sa
dépense par habitant ainsi 62 % des
écarts de dépenses entre deux communes
s'expliquent par des écart de niveau de
recette avant des écarts de charges ou
des différences de choix politique il
existe donc clairement à la lumière de
ce rapport des marges de réduction de la
dépense tocal mais celles-ci ne vont pas
bien entendu sans certaines conditions
alors c'est dans ce contexte que la
conférence sur les déficits public a
acté plusieurs mesures majeures pour les
prochaines années premièrement tout
d'abord comme le préconise le rapport de
Gill carz rapporteur général de la
commission des finances de l'Assemblée
et du préfet tau les concours financiers
de l'État aux collectivités locales
seront on le sait gelé en valeur à
partir du budget triénal
2011-2013 parallèlement la péréquation
sur les dotations de l'État sera
renforcée deuxème point pour faire
schématique la dynamique des dépenses
sociales dans les départements ruraux
devra être traitée par un renforcement
de la péréquation et sera examiné en
priorité dans le cadre de la réforme de
la dépendance et 3isème point et et je
réponds là au sénateur alin Duffo et je
vous confirme monsieur le sénateur que
un moratoire se sera appliqué
immédiatement sur les normes
réglementaires concernant les
collectivités locales en dehors
d'éventuelles normes internationales
d'application obligatoire et pour cela
le rôle de la Commission consultative
d'évalu dévaluation des normes la CCEN
sera renforcé monsieur le Président et
cela figurit être pourrait être aussi de
nature à rassurer le sénateur François
Fortassin euh je rends aussi euh hommage
à à Alain à Alain Lambert président de
la CS pour le rôle éminent qu'il y joue
et qui est très important pour l'avenir
de des finances de nos collectivités
territoriales alors clairement ces ces
mesures vont permettre je le pense de
contribuer à l'optimisation des
ressources mais aussi de répondre à
certaines contraintes de gestion des
collectivités territorial et c'est le
second point que je voudrais aborder à
ce niveau il faut aller plus loin et
doter les collectivités territoriales
effectivement d'outils performants de
gestion mutualisé c'est toute l'ambition
de votre rapport collectif sur la
mutualisation des moyens des
collectivités territoriales moi j'ai
pris encore une fois connaissance avec
beaucoup d'intérêt des propositions que
vous formulez en matière de
mutualisation de moyens et de services
dans le cadre intercommunal en
particulier mais aussi au sein des
conseils généraux et comme la délégation
au collectivité territoriale et à la
décentralisation le gouvernement
souhaite agir et agir vite en la matière
alors qu'il s'agisse d'élargir les
possibilités de mutualisation dite
verticale au sein du bloc communal entre
les EPCI et leurs communes membres qu'il
s'agisse de favoriser entre les
départements et entre les régions le
recours à des mutualisations
conventionnelles
de type donc horizontal qu'il s'agisse
d'élargir les mutualisations au domaine
service fonctionnels au-delà des
compétences exercées qu'il s'agisse de
sécuriser le développement des
mutualisations au regard des contraintes
lourdes au niveau communautaire alors le
gouvernement sera à vos côtés pour
apporter aux collectivités territorial
les outils nécessaires et vous le voyez
cher monsieur le Président al Lambert
nous sommes loin d'une attitude timoré
en matière de mutualisation croyez-moi
pour autant pour autant je souhaiterais
insister sur un point relatif à la
coopération intercommunale il me semble
en effet nécessaire de de clarifier ce
que nous voulons sur la mutualisation
intercommunale et je note que le rapport
relève que je cite que la mutualisation
doit compléter
l'intercommunalité elle ne doit ni la
concurrencer ni si substituer c'est ce
que vous écrivez en toute logique dans
ce rapport et cela plaide à mon avis
messieur les sénateurs Yve de Treg et et
Jacques mzard en faveur d'une
mutualisation mennée de préférence au
niveau de la structure intercommunale
alors cette ambition partagée de
progresser dans la mutualisation nous
allons la mettre en œuvre très
concrètement et je voudrais tout d'abord
vous préciser que le premier ministre a
souhaité lancer un travail concerté
avec l'Assemblée des départements de
France autrement dit la DF sur la
question de la situation financière des
départements parmi les thèmes de travail
un groupe de travail sera lancé sur la
question des mutualisations que que per
jamais le le DGS dur rô a
particulièrement développé dans son
rapport au Premier ministre alors les
pistes là aussi sont multiples
mutualisation de fonction support entre
département S10 un point important euh
entre ce 10 eux-mêmes et le sénateur
Vestri a évoqué ce ce point en
particulier la volonté du Premier
ministre et de faciliter la mise en
œuvre de ces préconisations et je suis
donc convaincu que nous trouverons
collectivement des réponses concrètes au
diagnostic posés par votre collègue
Bruno sidau sur la mutualisation des
moyens des conseils généraux nous allons
aussi et surtout développer la la
mutualisation grâce aux apports de la
réforme des collectivités territoriales
vous le savez plusieurs articles ont été
introduits et certains amendés ici même
par le Sénat en vue de développer la
mutualisation et concrètement nous avons
nous avons poursuivi trois objectifs
sécuriser la mis à disposition de de
service 2 favoriser la gestion unifiée
de servicees 3 organiser la
mutualisation de moyens ainsi dans un
premier temps l'article 33 dans cette
loi pour objectif de régulariser
vis-à-vis du droit communautaire de la
concurrence les conventions de mise à
disposition de service entre les
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale et leurs communes membres
il a été proposé notamment d'encadrer
les conditions de remboursement des
frais de fonctionnement pour éviter
qu'il soit considéré comme la
contrepartie d'une prestation de service
quant aux articles 34 et 34 bis ils
définissent le cadre d'une mise en en
commun des services au profit des
couples communes interco et département
région et là aussi le le Sénat don dans
l'élaboration de ce texte a joué un rôle
majeur alors tout d'abord pour les
couples communes interc le Gouvernement
a souhaité afin de garantir la la la
sécurité juridique des initiatives
locales et pour inciter à ces bonnes
pratiques créer expressément le régime
de mutualisation de servicees hors champ
de compétenence transféré à
l'intercommunalité le service commun
ainsi créé sera rattaché à
l'intercommunalité l'article 34 permet
même afin de de générer des économies
d'échelle à une structure intercommunale
d'acquérir des biens qui seront mis à la
disposition des communes pour exercer
des compétences qui n'ont pas été
transférées c'est c'est une chose qui
est importante d'autre part en en ce qui
concerne le couple département région
l'article 34 B a d'origine par
parlementaire d'ailleurs d'origine
sénatoriale l'autorise à se doter de
service commun et à conclure des
conventions je cite pour pour assurer en
commun leur mission de service public et
cette convention n'est pas soumise au
droit commun de la concurrence car elle
respecte les critères jurisprudentiels
définis par la Cour de justice
européenne en matière de marché public
vous le voyez les modalités
d'optimisation des moyens des
collectivités seront mises en œuvre très
rapidement et elles contribueront au
souhait de conférence de cohérence
territoriale évoqué par beaucoup d'entre
vous et notamment par le sénateur pierre
Hérisson d'ailleurs le rapport de votre
délégation nous montre à quel point ces
nouvelles voies devront être mises en
œuvre avec une grande célérité c'est une
obligation vis-à-vis de la trajectoire
de nos finances publiques c'est une
obligation pour la qualité des services
publics locaux c'est une obligation pour
le citoyen alors monsieur le Président
Lambert nous serons très attentifs donc
aux évolutions de notre droit national
comme vous l'avez indiqué parce que là
vous avez touché un sujet tout à fait
essentiel et les notions de bonus malus
méritent également d'être exploré comme
vous le suggurez conformément aux
conclusions d'ailleurs de la récente
conférence des déficits publics présidé
récemment par le chef de l'État je vrais
succintement mais j'espère le
faire avec avec force répondre aux
interventions de chacun d'entre vous de
chacun des sénateurs qui a pris la la la
parole en respectant monsieur le
présidentme une durée minimum dans mon
intervention monsieur le sénateur de
trgne pression très bien mais je sens
qu'elle vient je sens qu'elle vient
c'est pour ça je me permettis de le dire
monsieur le sénateur de Treng vous
proposz d'autoriser une partie des
communes membres d'un EPCI à mutualiser
des moyens pour exercer des compétences
non transférées à le PCI nous pourrions
donc avoir au sein d'un même EPCI deux
régimes différents en fait d'une part
une mutualisation dite verticale
réalisée au niveau de l'EPCI pour des
compétences transféré et d'autre part
une mutualisation dite horizontale euh
au niveau de quelques communes
volontaires pour des conférences pour
des compétences pardon non transférées
voilà j'ai j'ai résumé je pense ne pas
avoir trahi votre pensée je comprends
l'intérêt de votre proposition notamment
sur des compétences non structurante à
l'échelon intercommunal tel que le
fleurissement comme vous l'avez évoqué
pour autant il faut prendre garde je
pense au freins éventuels que cette
proposition pourrait constituer sur le
développement des projets communautaire
et tout particulièrement sur l'évolution
vers un exercice plus intégré des des
compétences communales au sein des
EPCI source d'économie d'échelle à moyen
terme je suis persuadé pour ma part que
la réflexion peut et doit se poursuivre
notamment avec votre assemblée afin de
trouver le bon équilibre je suis certain
monsieur le sénateur que nous allons le
trouver ensemble euh madame beoffil elle
est partie mais je vais quand même lui
répondre madame le sénateur vous
craignez que la mutualisation conduise à
la disparition des petites communes dont
les services seraient dissus au profil
de mutualisation à l'échelon
intercommunal au contraire madame befice
l'article 34 du projet de réforme des
collectivités prévoit que les
intercommunalités pourront acquérir des
biens qui seront ensuite mis à
disposition de leur commune membrees
pour l'exercice de leur propres
compétences comme ce pourrait être le
cas en matière de viabilité hivernal par
l'acquisition de chasse-neige voilà
c'est un sujet important ça me concerne
particulièrement dans mon département je
pensais pas qu'en André Loir vous aviez
autant de neige mais je réponds à votre
question euh elle arrive très bien alors
si elle arrive je vais répondre aussi au
au principe de la compensation
financière des transferts de compétences
la compensation financière des
transferts de compétences est inscrite à
l' à l'article 722 de la institution ces
modalités ont été fixées par la loi du
13 at 2004elle répondre à quatre
principes cardinaux un une compensation
intégrale de une compensation
concomitante 3 une compensation
contrôlée la CCC donne son avis
préalablement à tout transfert de charge
4 une compensation conforme au principe
constitutionnel d'autonomie financière
la compensation financière a
principalement pris la forme de
transfert d'impôts je vous rappelle que
en 2010 les compensations de la loi
ll la loi sur les liberté et les
responsabilités locales représentent
6,3 milliards d'euros près de 2
milliards 8 pour les départements 3
milliards 3 pratiquement pour les
régions 124 millions d'euros pour les
régions d'outrem qui ne perçoivent pas
de TIPP et 27 millions pour les communes
PCI et 27 millions pour le syndicat des
transports
d'Île-de-France si si l'on ajoute la
compensation du RMI de la pas et de la
PCI le total des montants versés au
titre des compensations atteint
18,5 milliards d'euros pour cette année
quant à l'effort financier madame bofice
de l'État en faveur des collectivités
territoriales permet de de rappeler que
un l'enveloppe dite normée des concours
financiers de l'État s'élève à 57
milliards d'euros soit 676 millions
d'euros de plus qu'en 2009
elle progresse au rythme de l'inflation
2 en prenant compte en compte les
subventions des différents ministères et
la contrepartie des dégrèvement
législatif atteint 78 milliards d'euros
et 3 en prenant en compte la fiscalité
transférée l'effort financiers total
consenti par l'État atteint
97,5 milliards d'euros cette année
l'effort financier de l'État en faveur
des collectivités territoriales reste
donc massif j'ai l'habitude de dire que
c'est l'équivalent de le l'équivalent du
budget de la Belgique mais depuis
dimanche je vais peut-être le dire un
peu moins voilà c'est une référence je
vais trouver une autre référence
importante avec un pays européen un peu
plus stable voilà sur sur le F7 et va le
plan de relance un mot parce que la
question étaé évoquée permettez-moi en
en deux phrases de faire le le bilan de
cette mesure du plan de relance ce sont
plus de 19500 collectivités qui ont
signé l'an dernier une convention avec
l'État pour bénéficier du remboursement
anticipé du FCT TVA c'est un succès et
je je saisis l'occasion une nouvelle
fois pour remercier les collectivités
pour l'État cela a aussi représenté un
effort supplémentaire de 3,8 milliards
d'euros en 2009 et cette mesure de
remboursement anticipé vous le savez a
été prorogée en 2010 et là aussi le le
Premier ministre a proposé de reconduire
la mesure cette année en faveur des
collectivités qui ne s'étent pas engagé
ou qui n'avait pas pu s'engagé l'an
dernier à ce stade aujourd'hui 2500
conventions supplémentaires ont été
signées monsieur le sénateur adnaud et
également je je vrais répondre au au
sénateur monsieur le sénateur jeanerau
vous êtes tous les deux des présidents
éminents de conseils généraux et je
voudrais vous apporter quelques élément
é de de prospective car le gouvernement
n'est pas resté inactif face à la
situation financière c'est vrai dégradé
des
départements bon rappelle que le premier
ministre avait demandé à Pierre jamaet
DGS durô d'établir un rapport sur la
situation financière des département les
conclusions de ce rapport ont été
discuté entre le Premier ministre et le
président de l'Assemblée des
départements de France le 1emier juin
dernier de son bureau plusieurs groupes
de travail vont être lancés afin
d'étudier les pistes de actualisation
d'économie d'amélioration de
l'organisation des services des conseils
généraux un dispositif de suivi va être
mis en place les départements qui
s'estimeraient en grande difficulté
pourrai alors s'engager dans un contrat
de stabilité par lequel il pourrait
recevoir une avance bon vous l'avez dit
en échange d'un programme de
stabilisation de leur dépenses et le
sénateur Alain Duffo l'a également
rappelé
euh le Premier ministre a même par
parler de dotation de dotation
financière pour les cas des départements
les plus en difficulté bien entendu de
dotations complémentaires et
exceptionnelles vous savez enfin que la
réforme de l'indépendance autrement dit
pour la pas sera lancée d'ici la fin de
l'année et il sera entre nous question
de bien entendu de son financement
et conclure en rappelant qu'un effort
particulier va être mené en faveur de la
péréquation et elle devrait euh cet
effort devrait bénéficier au
départements bien entendu les plus en
difficulté ou les plus pauvres un
élément d'optimiste d'optimisme quand
même jeaais rappeler parce que c'est un
moyen une recette importante pour
beaucoup de départements les les
DMTO depuis le début de l'année ont
augmenté en moyenne nationale hein c'est
pas certains
départements les plus urbains et les
autres augmentant pas en moyenne
nationale il y a une augmentation des
DMTO depuis janvier 4 mois consécutif de
plus de 40 % voilà c'est ça va quand
même dans le bon sens face au besoin de
financement des collectivités
territoriales le Sénat cherche des
solutions et prône la mutualisation une
mise en commun des moyens pour optimiser
les résultats cet après-midi place aux
questions d'actualité il sera bien sûr
largement question de la réforme des
retraites une réforme dévoilée hier par
le gouvernement le Premier ministre sera
présent dans les hémicycle des questions
d'actualité que vous pourrez suivre en
direct sur public sénna à partir de 15h
très bonne
journée